two it is the H3 podcast coming at you
live from beautiful Los Angeles
Sunny little cold today waste winner day
January 23rd of the 23rd year of our
Lord Jesus Christ
[Music]
welcome everybody it is bat we are back
with another week of live entertainment
for you nobody's doing it like us
and the whole world
nobody
yeah yeah welcoming back Sam
Sam is back yes how was your break Sam
it was great it was really fun got a new
car lots of excitement Sam got a new car
first new car yeah the first one that
like I've entirely bought by myself so
yeah
love that we'd love to see it we love to
see it
um not a Jeep not a Jeep not a Jeep I
got a 2023 Subaru Outback and I love it
I love it so much
um I test drove a lot of jeeps actually
and ultimately I decided to go with this
one so Subaru you know it's a great car
I you know as far as like consumer
reviews I don't think Jeep gets good
reviews but Subaru does yeah I mean uh
they're just notoriously like reliable
cars so I just decided to go with that
and I'm really happy with my toys so
there it is and you drove that cross
country I did yeah Ian did too Ian flew
out and he drove 30 hours so anything to
report interesting from a 30-hour road
trip cross country Texas is Big Texas
took forever yeah I swear it took like
six hours to get across like the
panhandle of Texas like just the top how
many days did it take you guys to do the
drive we did it in three three days so
y'all were hauling ass that whole time
yep whoa yep
so any surprises along the way there's
just a bunch of grass eh
boring yeah so the it was really nice it
was fun
congratulations thank you you're not
coming to my car close the trunk
dude bro you almost I was almost not
happy with that
so inappropriate Zach almost
oh yeah yeah so anyway guys welcome we
have a great show planned here today a
really fun a really fantastic show
talking about MILF Manor of course
I don't know how many of y'all have
heard of this show but it is taking the
World by storm when I saw the name I
knew I had to see it a dilf no MILF
Manor
um
I didn't know anything about it I didn't
even know that it was like taking off
because I now there's lots of people
buzzing about I said MILF Manor
you know that's going to be good the
premise of this show is so it's a bunch
of MILFs quote unquote older ladies show
up at a manner what is a manner is that
doesn't include some lordship yes uh I
don't know if it's really a manner it's
probably more of a mansion bring in the
middles yeah but yeah welcome to Milf
Manor that's mommy makeup I mean does it
take place uh in the UK
no it takes place in Calabasas
in Mexico oh yeah Mexico Mexico okay
where incest laws are relaxed no I'm
just kidding I don't know
MILF Manor announcing her lordship
Jezebel big titty Jezebel the MILF mommy
makeout day
foreign
adult interest even bigger titties than
the last MILF
MILF number two Kaylee just said my
husband's co-worker is on the show
[Music]
as the mill for the or the men or the
boys they're really boys wait let me
just let me just tell you the premise of
MILF Manor so all these old old ladies
and they're old I mean they're like 50
plus
um show up to date younger guys by the
way these MILFs they're not even like
Rich they're just like normal ass people
because there's nothing there's nothing
about being rich and just in that
acronym baby no no no no no no way and
so they introduced the guys do you know
the premise of this Dan I do so they
introduce the guys and the guys are all
the sons of all the MILFs there it's so
insane that is so insane and in the
first episode they had a competition
where the MILFs had to feel up all the
shirtless guys and identify which one
was their son oh come on yeah yeah and
they were getting really touchy with
somebody what is going on yeah dude and
and I was like okay they're gonna feel
everyone up I was like surely the sun's
not going to be in there that's
inappropriate and then they're like you
have to identify which one of them is
your son oh bro [__] your mom
the producers of that show need to be we
need a thorough background check because
you have to be a little bit hooked to
imagine of something like that absurd
absurd so that's MILF Manor would talk
about that yeah
I haven't decided yet if it's a good
show or not but I'm watching advise's
mom's
let's see MILF Manor executive producer
yeah we need to take the madman behind
we need to find out who's the show
runner here
show who's a famous incest person do
they exist is there a famous incest
person oh Woody Allen produced by Woody
Allen oh
that's [__] up showrunner Woody Allen
I mean that was this no no no no no no
stepdaughter this is worse no no no what
he [__] his biological daughter too
he did both okay yeah yeah he did both
interesting guy that Woody Allen
dude Alec Baldwin remember his ass he
had like Woody Allen on to be like I
don't believe them Woody's my hero and
now he's going to jail for killing
someone it's the Matrix dude public is
having a hard stretch
um did you see the video actually I
can't believe I forgot about this we
should have maybe we can just pull it up
impromptu right now on the show the
video of um Alec Baldwin's wife uh
responding to the um news of him being
charged no but I know that she's a whole
meme too about faking an accident yeah
in her response she was laying that fake
Spanish accent oh she's still sticking
with it I want it dude she's sticking
with it dude some of these people on
Tick Tock really showing up so oh there
you go clown emojis maybe uh maybe just
uh all right dropped it yes I think we
need some kind of special episode or
report on The Life and Times of Alec
Baldwin with like about his wife
about the shooting about the Woody out
he loves Woody Allen I guess there's not
that much to it really
tell you what I'm gonna say you're not
gonna
she's talking like that bro you've heard
nothing so far I better tell you she's
like so over the top like Lucy like I
love Lucy's husband I'm gonna tell you
something she's very performative with
it what
oh yeah all these Chargers I'm gonna
tell you what I'm gonna say you're not
gonna ask me questions
okay I want you guys to realize that we
have seven kids and you being here
to escort them to school and to be there
when they come home is not good
so on a human level you guys know
Griffin
[__] it you know that
so please
leave my family in peace and let this
all play out okay so let my kids come
home
and you stay away from them because they
ask me mommy
what like what are these people doing
and it's a very hard thing as a mom to
try to explain so please go home because
I'm not going to say anything and Alec
is not going to say anything your
lawyers have said something about the
charges what do you say about them she's
from Boston by the way what the [__] did
she grow up in Spain or what like how is
she justifying this her parents are
professors yeah and she says that she
commuted but people online say that she
just like vacationed
and but she is bilingual wait what does
it mean commuted like she said that she
lived in Spain and uh us but when did
she live in Spain that's what I need to
know was she there from like zero to
like 15 or was she there for like a
month in her you know what I mean
I just wanted to tell you something
I was born in Boston this is a quote I
spent time in Boston and in Spain my
family now lives in Spain I moved to New
York when I was 19 years old and I have
lived here ever since but her parents
are from the U.S wait if she yeah but if
she grew up in Spain then the accent
would be real if she moved here when she
was 19 no no no no no she was born in
Boston yeah and then she spent time in
Boston and she says also and in Spain
people are saying she did not live there
I just need I need the full
I need her full life story
someone says she's not even bilingual
I asked you said you something
dude that's crazy but and what is there
videos clips of her without the accent
like yeah I've seen it in the past yeah
dude I mean I grew up in Southern
California so
yeah I've just been surrounded by the
culture
yes yes
all right well I don't see what the big
deal is
oh here here's a video about it I stand
her we got let's let's watch this whole
five minute video about this [__] Jesus
now this
bro you can't be playing that music over
here
wait wait okay
play open the volume
thank you
what was it the circus music [__]
you guys find a good clip I'll watch it
okay yeah super exciting announcement
Rebecca Black is coming this Friday it's
a little earlier than usual 11 A.M 11
A.M start time Rebecca Black this Friday
I am so freaking excited I am so
freaking pumped you guys
um I have so many questions for from
Patrice Wilson Friday baby yeah I want
to know how this all got got going
also
she's now making like good music what a
crit what an interesting thing that
she's stuck with it she has several fans
here in the office that's true what I
understand dude Rebecca Black is
happening
it's her time dude it's so I have so
many questions it's gonna be so such an
awesome interview so yeah I'm excited
that she's gonna be on Friday
it's Friday and on Friday
I know I know Friday is she gonna be is
she gonna be pissed if I go it's Friday
oh we should have Cape sing It's Friday
to her I actually thought about that
let's go I mean is she trying to like
escape from from meme status because
then she didn't mention like don't she
didn't say like don't mention this I
think she's she's real Dan she's
literally real she keeps it real real
it's Friday baby Friday baby it's Friday
everybody get down on Friday baby Friday
baby
remixed uh Friday like a year and a half
ago oh for real yeah is it fire
oh it's great I've listened to it a
bunch of times it's great wow I wonder
if she had to pay out Patrice royalties
on that he is the songwriter the
probably yeah yeah
and what did she do about his verse in
the remix did she did does she wrap it
did she get a new yeah
there are new there are new features
that verse is gone oh no sorry but he's
iconic though the world has moved on
it's a bummer it's a bummer yeah well so
that's exciting also I want to say we
don't have sponsors today so let me just
shout out Teddy fresh this is a new hat
with a rubber patch it's very beautiful
very nice feels great blocks this has
super Sun blocking ability
really how does that work the beams back
to the Sun and it's renewable it this is
this uh stiff part that's at the front
right here the Pfizer huh it reflects
the sun back and then the sun lives
longer it's gonna blow up longer out
because it got some of the beams back oh
it kind of like restores some of the
energy I was lost yeah stop the Sun from
being hot
also this is kind of just a nice what
well well I don't know that that's how
global warming works but that's kind of
what I'm doing
it's crazy
um this is also a really nice classic
you guys are gonna see with the rubber
patch and it's just a beautiful fitted
nice wonderful shirt
teddyfrish.com go ahead check it out all
kinds of cool stuff there I'm wearing a
long sleeve of that oh show it off oh
damn you look good in that boy thank you
okay okay damn all right God damn yeah
there's hoodie there's this cool oh
coming soon this is not out yet vintage
bomber
runx this shirt my badass tee thick
which I guess is almost sold out but
there's a few left love this one also
Dan's rocking
what do you want apparently this wasn't
new and I I missed it I mean it is new
at least this nice flannel I really dig
it that's nice it came out I think a few
months ago so it's not super old
but there it is thank you thank you with
peace and love this is a serious message
see Ed reminded me Dan doesn't look good
in anything so don't don't judge it
based off of what you're seeing right
now
good ignore this just pay attention to
this yeah tomorrow I'll be going live
for our members see you next Tuesday
thank you to all of our wonderful
beautiful members who I love
actually I don't know when it's going to
be because I might be going to Aiden
Ross's house I was going to say
unannounced but this is announced he
sent me his he was doing a meme he was
talking about me
responding to my video I made about him
called uh urgent messenger Aiden Ross
about him being in the Matrix [__] and
he dm'd me his address
I didn't know why he sent it to me at
the time I said what do you what do you
want to do and he never responded and so
I saw the clip finally and he was like
yo I'm gonna send Ethan my address right
now I really want to hook up with them
and meet up So I says all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna show up at Aiden
Ross's house tomorrow by myself
I hope he's streaming at the time too
because I really want to show him that
people you you really think his his
homies are gonna like no me of course
not no [__] no no but I really hope
that we get to uh have a moment together
I want to get there
he's gonna see it now so I think maybe
it's better this way instead of me just
showing up totally unannounced I don't
know that is kind of a Vibe too but it's
too late in the bag [__] you
people are saying do not come on what
are they gonna do oh you people you guys
think I'm gonna end up on an episode of
Dateline they're not going to
well he's this weird in between of hater
and a big fan because if you watch his
stuff he's clearly a big big A3 fan and
has been for a long time he knows the
lore yeah no he's a good right and I'm a
fan too yeah
do not go alone come on you guys stop it
I'm going by myself that's the vibe that
I'm going for you gotta go with me baby
no no just Morpheus yeah what do you you
don't need backup you gotta go in there
and tell him yo you're in trouble I
wasn't so I was gonna do that bro dude
recreate the whole moment you're a
crypto [__] that crypto [__] yo what if
I get on the stream though and then I my
career gets ruined for yeah that's why
you shouldn't go alone I'm worried about
that well what no no no what are we
gonna do
Keem didn't go alone right right true I
think it's better to fly solo you're in
trouble well the one thing I wanted to
try and do was to just show him and
Aiden if you're watching this there's
one specific clip from Hustler's
University that I want to watch with you
the one that we showed Bradley if I
could just watch that one clip with you
on stream I'll never say that I'll never
say anything about Andrew I'll never say
anything bad about him again
I'll never give you [__] again for being
a tater tot
ever
that's not true I no it is true I
promise if he if we can do this and he
just hears me out I'll never bring it up
again I'm the one getting plowed and
I'll support him forever Aiden Ross
forever
gambling
manosphere whatever bro I got your back
forever
people saying bring a b you ready to
throw down I could wait in the car
because one of his homies said he was it
was on site he was going to beat my ass
yeah they're not doing they're not going
to yeah that's what I thought [__]
it's a bunch of luster no I'm not scared
I'm gonna give him a hug and say what's
up thanks for not beating me up
um
but I think that'd be good content Aiden
let me know what you think
well it doesn't matter what he thinks he
sent the address you're showing up yeah
the thing is his his streaming schedule
is kind of erratic I see which is part
of why I mention it now even at all
right
um
someone saying bring Swami armed Swami
with a gun
That'd Be Wild
yeah so we'll see hopefully he's willing
to uh to bring me in and
we'll have a little bit of a moment we
can talk
there it is
[Music]
Aiden this is your father speaking
you've been a very naughty boy
I have some important life lessons to
teach you my boy
one
human trafficking is not cool Aiden Ross
and here's why
it it includes having people do things
they don't want to do have you heard of
The Golden Rule Sun
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
it's the Golden Rule my boy
rape for example
not something I would recommend to you
Aiden as your father or to even support
people who do that
once again going back to the Golden Rule
do you want to be raped Aiden I didn't
think so
do unto others as you want done unto you
[Music]
yes Aiden my boy the adoption papers are
going through the system as we speak
we got you the race car bed just like
you asked for
the Bugatti bed
what color is your Bugatti bed ate in
your room's almost ready the Bugatti bed
and the glow-in-the-dark stars on the
roof
dinosaur wallpaper we love you son
please come home
you can stream from home but you must
stop at eight that's when family time
begins dead dinosaurs we can play
Monopoly we can play Risk but you can
play Bingo whatever you want Aiden
special family times important Yahtzee
no nyatzi in this house
satanic what Yahtzee is satanic Dan
I'm never coming home
you're mean dad [__] you dad [__] you
dad I always hated you you're not my
real dad
yeah let's uh let's do this Aiden baby
wants baby wants baby sad
so um let's see
oh yeah here's something I want to say
now we had was Bradley last week all the
time having weird time warp when he
called into leftovers yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah that was there okay let's talk
about this
Bradley Martin
Dr Bradley Martin Martin
um called into the show
and had a long discussion with me and
Hassan
about Andrew Tate
now I know a lot of people
got angry
at Bradley and I totally understand that
it's frustrating right to hear somebody
when confronted with something that
seemed so self-apparent to you
not get it especially something as
important as
trafficking and consent and stuff like
that
but here's the thing where I want to
urge you guys
if we want to make a change if we want
to affect these people we cannot turn on
them you have to acknowledge this
most of those guys would have never even
called in right Bradley
is a genuine enough a guy to even call
in and talk about it
and he stayed on the phone
as we kind of just
slammed him for a long time and we even
got through to him at the end I think a
little bit
a little bit seem like it so I just
think I I think that the amount of hate
he's getting is don't say don't defend
him shut up this is important
it's it we're never gonna get anywhere
y'all just want to you all want to make
him sound like he's the demon Bradley's
not a demon okay he's a guy he's a guy
he's a normal guy and he's a nice guy
and so if y'all if y'all gonna see you
know all nice guys like [__] they're
all demons we're not how we ever gonna
affect any change right that was the
point of the conversation is I wanted to
talk to Bradley and I wanted to see if I
can get through to him and so like if if
if the response to anyone trying to you
know have a genuine conversation with me
is that our fans go crazy and call them
like all these horrible things and just
[__] hate him and Bradley he actually
texted me afterwards he's like damn your
fans are vicious
I was like I said yeah you know it's
it's a sensitive topic so I understand
people getting upset but at the same
time I'm not blaming anybody you don't
need to feel bad but I just do want to
express my opinion that
if we want to affect change
we have to be a little more tolerant and
I know y'all some are disgusted by like
his ignorance or his lack of wanting to
understand but you got to remember he's
a normal guy he's a dude he's just a
dude okay he's BR you know what I mean
if if if he's a write-off then then
there's no hope for anybody because he's
a nice guy and he's willing to listen
and that says a lot more like when we
all attack him he's just in the future
he'll just shut down he's just not going
to have those conversations and he's
just going to be like well those people
hate me anyway so
uh what's the point so this is just my
opinion
obviously criticism is fine but I felt
that some of some of it was a little too
vicious
because I I really did appreciate him
coming on and having the conversation
and I felt like he regretted it after he
got eviscerated by
by some people in this audience so you
know I can't control what all y'all do
but I did want to voice that opinion you
know now because he um
he he reached out to you and told you
that that our fans were uh viscerating
him or whatever but we're not talking
about the comments section of like the
episode right we're talking about like
DMS and I don't know he didn't say I I
was just basing it off I figured that he
was getting like comments on his
personal Instagram and like DMS and that
kind of stuff I don't know I wasn't
looking and he didn't give me specifics
he just says your fans are vicious
and I did see some of the discourse
afterwards and and you know on the
subreddit and the comments so I see I
knew what he was talking about
so yeah I mean
just my opinion you know and again I
totally understand y'all get being upset
too at the same time you know
uh it's it's frustrating and it's and
it's hard and it's gross especially
if you've been a victim and it feels
like you can't get through to anyone
you know what this this whole
conversation's so so funny because
I was watching Dateline I love True
Crime as you guys know
and there was this guy
he R worded this girl
she did everything right she did the kit
she went to the hospital she went
straight to the police
and there's video of the police being
like
okay well are you sure it happened that
way you know are you sure that what's he
gonna say that you know he probably you
wanted it and you just regretted it the
police brought him in for a polygraph
which he passed by the way polygraphs is
the biggest pseudoscience [__] it's
totally fake like the only way
polygraphs are actually effective is
when the interviewer can leverage it to
manipulate you to self-conf confession
so he passed this polygraph and then
they brought her back in and he's like
is there some this guy like was fully
convinced that that meant he was
innocent so she goes are you is there
something that you're not telling me you
know uh is there did this guy do
something like he starts like cueing her
up to like charge her for a false claim
or some [__] and she's like you know
what I'm just gonna drop the case I I
don't want to be here anymore well it
turns out this guy went on to murder an
R were two additional women Jesus and
that cop at the time had the opportunity
to stop him and he didn't [__]
believe the victim
um and this is the kind of thing this is
an extreme example but this is the kind
of thing that's out there in the world
so I totally understand
your guys's reaction that's all but you
know at the same time
I do think it's good he came on the show
so there you go peace why are they still
even allowed to use lie detectors like
it's not just it's not permissible in
court I know it's not but then they
still do it like you said is like almost
an intimidation tactic or whatever and
it it's kind of insane well this cop was
a [__] [__] super well you said he
was a cop so yeah he he's he has no
training like they show the on yeah
thank you Dan yeah [__] the police I'm
with you yeah but they show on video he
goes the he's talking to the polygraph
guy and he says I didn't detect any
lying and then the cop goes okay so yeah
it's all good I didn't think this he's
like he's he's innocent I'm gonna let
him go like that's it dude he took that
[__] as gospel it's not a Magic Machine
bro yeah and the more psycho you are the
more likely you are to pass it by the
way
right I've seen things that like
trying to get like a true or false out
of a polygraph like you're almost better
off just guessing like that's how like
inaccurate they are
they can be at no I think they're
I do think they're accurate to an extent
they can be it just it measures your
vital signs you know
and the theory is that when you lie
your heart rate goes up or your blood
pressure goes up or something like that
I don't know but it really it's just a
pseudoscience you know
also if you just squeeze your butthole
you can throw the whole thing off
because it raises your blood pressure
that's where to God seems like
pretty big uh flaw literally all you got
to do is clench your ass cheeks and the
whole thing will make no sense hell yeah
thank you for the gifted Jade sir day oh
going too fast
going too fast eat out my ass
can you put those uh dominoes and gifts
and well there's sit for skit with a
five member I don't know thank you
Mr E says love you guys the fan needs to
get some perspective Bradley was coming
around this performative holier than
thou crap is why the left loses on
issues save the hate for those who have
gone too far like Andrew Tate
I agree but like like I said
it's a very sensitive topic so I
understand why people get so angry you
know and then in a sense this community
is kind of like a very safe place for
women and and and uh abuse victims so in
a way it's like they it should be
allowed to vent because this is a good a
safe and good place for them to do that
but well that's kind of why I asked
about I guess I didn't real I just
assumed that Bradley was getting hate
privately from our fans which I would
say is too far if he's simply talking
about people ragging on him in our
comment section frankly
I don't see an issue with that I mean
you get hate on YouTube all the time
like who doesn't you know what I mean
and a lot of it you know the criticism
is deserved
um
but if it you know if people are going
out of their way to like you're [__]
sending them DMs like you're a [__]
piece of [__] [__] you or whatever and
he's getting a bunch of that kind of
stuff sure there was some of that that's
too far but uh Shea says can we hear Sam
Olivia
uh Ela and Lena's opinion Shea is
demanding Shay that the women speak
she's demanding
[Music]
um
I don't know I mean like I don't know
what you want me to say yeah I think
pretty it's the conversation
took a little bit longer than I thought
it would to maybe get through to him but
by the end he was willing
to hear new ideas and clearly in his
world like he's being told
the complete opposite of what you guys
were trying to feed him so it was all
new to him it's hard to break through
that yeah
Prejudice yeah you know what I mean I'm
sure yeah I I agree I think he means
well
um and he was sort of coming around and
also I think that it's important to talk
to be able to talk about these things
without tearing the other side down
Lena the Great
a great uh
eight I don't know somebody said in all
caps don't tell women they need to like
bread
I didn't say you need to like it when
the [__] did I say that nobody that is
not a thing that's been said in fact I I
empathize with you not liking him okay
perfectly okay
you must like Brad you must like Bradley
Martin definitely not a requirement not
a requirement you must like keemstar or
just [__] your whole life up I thought
you uh I thought you really were hitting
on something at the end of that
conversation that was an angle I had
never really thought of before which is
the fact that somebody like Tate is so
psychotic and manipulative that the way
that he's likely been manipulating
people like Brad as well
um
I thought was really interesting because
yeah if you try and think of it from his
perspective you're Bradley you haven't
looked into any of this whether he left
or not when I said he's a psychopath he
laughed I says what's funny look at this
watch this video right right and I think
from his perspective
having gone out there like he went out
to wherever Romania or like one of those
places to meet him in person at one
point he was part of one of those trips
yeah yes I think so and has had all
these interaction with him and I think
you're right I think you know
to from his perspective he probably sees
when the camera goes off his personality
loosen up quite a bit probably you know
act a lot more relaxed and gives the
impression that it's all just a
character and he's just playing it up
and he doesn't really mean it and
everything and if that's his first
person experience having met this guy
multiple times and he just kind of comes
off as like yeah he says some crazy [__]
online but you know he's really just
playing it off
um
I can kind of see why he's just like
he sees all of this and he's like well
I've met the guy and he really didn't
seem like that at all so I I think this
is all [__] and he's wrong he is
crazy and like you said I I think he is
being manipulated as well as all of
these guys because he needs the exposure
he needs these people to advertise for
him essentially bro how much money did
milk and Adam Ross make him in the
Hustler University Millions
subscriptions millions and millions
yeah one of the most
uh the the most defining trait of a
psychopath is you know charming and
manipulative right right
wild
so anyway that you know not to keep
talking about Tate here uh Elijah said I
suggest being conscious of how much you
cover Tate becomes exhausting as a woman
to constantly be exposed to these people
and ideologies and endless debates over
your worth and existence
I hear that yeah
I'm trying I'm trying not to you know I
mean I'm just some things just I feel
like give the impression that there's a
debate because there isn't a debate like
there there's no debate with Tate he's
just fully wrong like there's no there's
no middle ground there and it's just a
matter of you know trying to inject some
sanity into the people in his orbit and
it already kind of worked I mean there
was that incident with Bradley he
already started to push back on the Note
guys a little bit which is why I think
it is a good thing that we engage with
somebody like him yeah I know Andrew
Tate is getting so old it's been talked
about so much and even myself but like
somehow
he's remained relevant because these
[__] people are still riding for him
and like that's just not
it was frustrating to me because I feel
like
the evidence is right there you just
gotta like you just gotta take their
head and make them do this right right
there yeah it's so close just in the
peripheral vision yeah it's frustrating
and his and Andrew Tate's influence is
still very strong he's uh on the young
men across the country so
it is exhausting I I hear you
I hope this whole thing does help to
break the grip a little bit though I
have to imagine that it does a little
bit like
now that he's in jail and the sex
trafficking accusations and it's so
public they're still waiting for him to
be acquitted you know so they're still
I'm sure there are those I just I hope
that there's some 13 year old boys
who like are having a moment of like oh
this guy's kind of creepy it's gonna
happen more and more right his stay got
extended by another 30 days I think he's
going to go to jail for many years and
when that happens it's going to become a
lot harder for these guys to
say anything nice about him
[__] yes
there it is book yes all right Andrew
Tate wrought in prison thank you thank
you thank you thank you yeah
thank you thank you
yeah guys I had this realization that
I'm not that I grew up
check this out you see this pimple here
so I'm at this point in my life where I
don't pick I don't touch I don't pop and
let me tell you
it goes away so [__] fast thank you
it's like incredible dude
no it's incredible argument for years
dude it's CR and so I'm at this point in
my life
I'm much I feel like I've ascended and
and it go it's just it really is
incredible to watch it's like one day of
gross and then it's gone like gone dude
and if you try to pop that [__] you're
you're stuck with it for a while and
it's gonna keep getting gross I'm
jealous hopefully I'll get there I can't
resist it like I hear it in my head
talking to me
you got to ascend bro you just got to
say you just gotta understand that it's
good it's better in the long run it's
gonna go away it disappears it's like
magic I I was a major popper when I like
started getting acne and there was a
period where I had it pretty bad around
like 14 15. uh I got pretty bad acne and
I I was popping like crazy and then a
dermatologist told me how bad that is
and that you really got to just resist
and I stopped doing it
and my acne got way [__] better like
immediately I mean popping is bad but
it's bad people I've always heard that
but like obviously I don't believe them
and I can't help it when I was a kid
go away Lena will like bribe me with
hers like if you do this I'll let you
pop this pimple oh wow I prefer that he
doesn't but
[Music]
you're popping her pimples where like on
her face she always does yeah I wouldn't
let him touch my face Lena
I I mean I even showed me I never used
to know that you could pop pimples and
then one years ago when we first met he
was showing me in the mirror and it
popped and I was just like mind blown I
hate it I know some like when I pop a
pencil and it like splashes on the
mirror Lena I don't remember the yeah
the first time I popped Lena's pimple
she goes she like freaked out when she
saw it on the mirror now the best is
when it makes two sounds one when it
pops and one when it hits the mirror oh
the double poppers I hate it I hate it
so much
it is satisfying I like doing it but I
don't because it's horrible and it just
makes your acne worse so just stop I
don't know I'll be okay I don't know for
like a whole day and then uh I'll wake
up and I'll have have it I've scratched
it up while I was sleeping so it doesn't
matter I just wow scratched it up
yeah when I sleep but scratch why would
you scratch it
at your pimple
[__] yeah bro it's itchy and uh I guess
sleepy me just what annihilate yeah go
back to Andrew Tate
yeah but that's it so I just you know
that's what it is the next level is when
you um put ice cubes on your pimple to
make it go away faster too
um that work yeah it reduces it and you
know it kind of satisfies like the pain
of it a little bit I guess it reduces
swelling yeah Ice Cube on pimple yeah to
like reduce the switch it says well
isolome may not cure a pimple it can
discreet swelling and redness and it
satisfies like the I don't know the the
fact that it's there it just helps to do
something instead of ice icing pimples
folks you know what I used to do it's
[__] I hate all this pimple [__] I
would take a little sewing needle and
pop it um
frankly squeeze it out as long as the
needle's sanitary that's probably better
yeah and then just make a tiny little
incision so it would like easily come
out I think that's how facialists do it
don't they really that's what I was
about to say yeah when they do
extractions if it's not coming out
easily they'll like prick it I hate all
this [__] I hate it so much do you so
Abby are you into pimple popping videos
uh sometimes I'll watch them but I'm not
like looking for them but if they come
up I'll occasionally I'll watch it my
brother like looks for them yeah
Olivia's nodding emphatically right now
pimple popping videos while I'm watching
something
yeah no I know what you mean yeah I need
to scroll and I need to be watching
blackheads
wait I don't understand you're saying
you like have multiple screens
whatever TV show I'm watching or if like
my friend is watching TV up there I'm
always I'm always I was like the kinetic
sand video uh yeah that Hassan you just
need like pimple popping in one of the
quadrons sometimes I look up kinetic
sand sometimes I look up pimple lovings
it's the Sumer brain if you guys recall
one of my first segments I suggested on
the show was the pimple popping and like
I was watching you and ELO like freak
out almost puke I'm like [__] was this a
bad idea but no I watched the gross
stuff like oh yeah show me any any video
and I'll watch it sometimes I click it
and it's like this giant [__] absent
the size of like my hand and I'm like
are you talking about a lipoma
I know the term I don't even like
knowing the word
oh so I tell Tick Tock to not show me
those videos whenever I come across him
I'm like this is Spam this is not
interesting these videos
although you got to be careful because I
do that on the animal abuse videos and I
just get more and more
if I lived those pimple popping videos
you guys seen me as a as a teenager with
like pizza face yeah I have like
flashbacks whenever I see them now there
was a period of time where mine was
almost as bad as those pictures you've
shown us cam yeah they got really bad
for me and guess what it was at the
height of me popping them all the time
not that bad yeah I wonder if you're
desensitized based on like how much acne
you had because I had a bunch so I was
like always come on we all did I don't
know what there's like that one kid who
has Perfect Skin their whole life and
just like [__] you dude but most of us
got you had Perfect Skin your whole life
I never had acne really yeah yeah not
even you not even a single one no I I
don't know if it's because of my well
I'm cursed otherwise I have a red
[__] face I was gonna say you kind of
have like another skin condition yeah
maybe they conflict somehow yeah no
there's some people that they just it
just doesn't have them I have dry skin I
don't I mean that probably helps because
the greasier you are the more you get it
yeah yeah
um but yeah I never had I never had acne
if you've never had a pimple and I've
had a pimple yet okay okay on my ass but
not usually on my face you know
and uh does your girlfriend pop the
pimples on your ass I wouldn't put her
through that no
all right so that's that it's just an
epiphany I wanted to share with you guys
you know I thought that was important do
you like popping pimples that's a good
pull
oh there's too many of you
have any of you had warts before warts
what do you do with those you freeze
them off yeah I I ran home I randomly
got one once in my life on this on my
finger I don't even know why and yeah I
did oh yeah I mean the cryo thing were
they you do it by yourself or you go to
a dermatologist I had a doctor do it
what do you can do it yourself
I froze mine myself on my hand yeah
there you go wait Lena you're talking
about freezing it yourself no my well my
doctor did it for me I was really young
and it was really embarrassing like at
school and I was in elementary school
and I had like a bunch of warts on just
these two fingers
um but my doctor was really old so he
wasn't like freezing directly on the
pimple he was freezing my skin and like
it would cause blisters to come up and
yeah I just I dealt with these like
nothing was working to get rid of these
warts until
I went to Lebanon One Summer I'm not
supposed to tell the story but I already
did a million times but this lady like
red could on it and she was she did this
like she did this kind of ritual it's a
magic and he did Magic on your dark arts
on your words she read the Quran
look I tried everything and my mom my
mom tried everything trying to help me
get rid of these warts and it didn't
work until that like the magic Ward lady
reverse okay okay all right all right
all right first of all I have why
shouldn't why are you not supposed to
tell that story by the way the lady who
did it she told me like it was really
weird she had an eggplant and then like
these little seeds and then she as she
was reading cut on she would like poke
the seed into the war and like have me
repeat something after her and then she
would put the seed into the eggplant and
then I would toss she then I put the
eggplant a bag and then we tossed it out
the building now that I think about it
it's very dangerous
building but yeah anyways she then she
gave me another bag with another
eggplant and she's like just tell your
family this is the eggplant we used and
don't tell anybody like what happened
here hold on hold on hold on okay first
all right how did you find this lady oh
she's okay well she's like a relative
sort of like a relative of a relative
she wasn't like totally a stranger and
why did she not want anyone to know
about the eggplant
I guess it has to do is it demonic I
don't know what it's actually called I
don't know how she is it demonic is it
frowned on no no it's kind of like like
fortune tellers yeah it's it's sort of
it's sort of my my grandmother that's
what she did for a living and like she
was really religious but like half of
you know the people in the community
really don't like it because they say
you're not supposed to is it um is it
the correct me if I'm completely wrong
here but the the Sufi thing
does it have anything to do with that
you know what I'm talking about like the
Mystic like the kind of more mystical
Islamic stuff I I know what you're
talking about I'm not sure if it falls
in that category though you know what do
you think yeah I don't know too much I
was really young when this happened
gotcha all right all right
you got this family friend whose idea
was it to go see her to pop these get
these warts off my mom
or your mom yeah so your mom's like yo I
need I got some witchcraft let's do this
so she brings really tell me what it was
um again I was I was super young just
that you know
come sit in the this room with this lady
and she's gonna do something for your
warts to help them go away so you go
into this room it's just some lady's
apartment yeah and then she sits you
down she got an eggplant and and she has
a needle what's going on oh no look it
was like a seed
she had a big seed that she poked the
Little Seeds no no
she would hope she would poke the my
wart and then take that seed and put it
inside the eggplant oh so she would take
the seed poke the war with the seed and
then put it into a different eggplant
there is only one eggplant there's only
one eggplant yeah all the seeds went to
the eggplant and then but then she gave
you a different eggplant at the end yeah
two times so my family doesn't know that
the the actual eggplant was thrown out
the window oh why would they even know
that why would what do they know about
eggplant at all I don't know and she
told me not to tell anyone about it too
and but it's been years and I told the
story a million times already so so she
poking your Wards she puts the seed back
in the eggplant the cursed eggplant that
now has your wart energy yes
and then is the eggplant cut in half or
how how is she no it was a whole like it
was just a whole had she put the seeds
back in it
she just she's like it's not an eggplant
seed like you could say it was maybe
like a sunflower seed or something like
that it was just Pokey okay so it's
different seed yeah poke it
put it back in put it slam it into an
eggplant push it into the eggplant and
how many times did she do that
um
I had like four warts and she poked each
wart like a few times so and then she
takes the eggplant and throws it out the
window no she gave it to me to throw out
the window and you threw it was it in a
bag or just by itself it was in a bag in
a tied bag and and how high up were you
a few floors up a few floors up and was
it a busy street below
um it was like it was in downtown Beirut
so probably so we're throwing a bat a
cur a bag of cursed eggplant yeah do you
think that eggplant energy is cursed if
somebody
were to pick it up and consume it do you
think that that would be bad
[Music]
dog eats it I'm just trying to get I'm
trying to understand this wart magic
yeah I
I didn't ask a lot of questions I didn't
ask any questions I just kind of trusted
my mom but
now I kind of wish I knew more so you
throw the eggplant out the window and
then you guys leave with the good
eggplant now how long does it take for
these warts to go away like they went
away so fast like honestly a couple
weeks later before I went back before we
flew back to the States
and
what what was the closest treatment you
had on the warts before the witchcraft
oh
it wasn't really working that well how
long before was it
[Music]
and then between that between the
this um there was like this war
treatment or whoa yeah she would put it
on those two like every single day
so we're sure it's the Witchcraft and
not the cream and that's crazy
so I gotta tell you it's not
totally uh coming out of nowhere because
when I uh Googled can eggplants cure
warts wow there's quite a lot of talk
about it it's all the boys in the
eggplant Siege just put the seed in the
eggplant I mean I guess it's true I'm
just saying that this is not the only
instance of uh somebody claiming
eggplant to have but the eggplant did
not touch your warts right I don't think
so yeah there's just an eggplant
did you guys eat the eggplant you took
home no oh I don't know what I probably
not
interesting and so and so have you
believed in witchcraft
um since that day
um well I will ever leave like in
spirits and things like that if
so I yeah I guess like superstitious
stuff I do believe if this woman can
cure your warts with just the touch of a
seed what else can she do right
[Music]
I'm just saying it makes you wonder
and she resolved the political crisis in
Lebanon perhaps I'm just saying come on
now gotta get her around on that yes
so okay there it is witchcraft is real
uh what's your take on this story Amy
uh nothing I've heard it a few times
I've heard Lena's mom mention it anytime
one of the other kids has warts like one
of the grandkids oh one time Lena got it
taken care of in Lebanon I don't know I
I mean I I'm not leaning towards uh
completely believing it but I don't
disbelieve it either I don't believe me
no I mean I believe I believe you're I
believe your story I mean but I don't I
believe it AP has reservations Lena
uh but yeah go ahead
[Music]
oh I don't know what else to say I mean
that that's just that's what happened
yeah no I'm not saying it didn't happen
I'm just saying um when these things
come up like with my grandmother reading
fortunes and [__] they were all pretty
pretty basic so but then some of them
are really true so I'm not sure this
isn't a fortune though this is this is a
or b is this is the word off this is a
word on ward off yeah two options this
is a bona fide miracle
I believe it
be gone warts I say God damn you warts
all I know is thank God I went there
because
it's not working for these boards so
the warts must have had some kind of
demonic curse and that's what are we
going to do
what God damn these warts to hell
amen is anybody out in here in the
audience have some warts need healing
from the power of Jesus
we'll see tomorrow if Lena wakes up with
a bunch of words because she talked
about it I always was worried about that
but like I said I told the story a
million times already and they haven't
come back well warts is caused by a
virus I wonder if she could help with
covid
oh you're asking for the bars you know
just a thought we gotta track her down
Lena for the bar is she still alive who
is she I'll ask my mom about her we
gotta get her in a lab
I'll find out I say be gone demonic
warts you're asking for the bar these
warts appeared on your hand after two
gay men kissed in Idaho
every time a man kiss another man
another wart appear on a poor
defenseless child
[__]
and then when a man kiss a woman
the war to be gone it's a war out there
of the war it's a gays and Saiyan
and God
you ain't never seen heart and
heterosexual love just like it's
supposed to be
oh Jesus Jesus begotten Watts
just be lucky just be happy Lena them
warts only on your finger because those
two gay men
[Music]
they only had fellatio but if they
committed soda me you would have been
Comfort amen hallelujah Hallelujah Jesus
is good God is good and they said well
you know
what the [__] was that one I brought I
brought a little girl in my office her
finger was infected with warts I brought
my wife out I gave her a heterosexual
kiss
and those Wars under God's eyes
disappeared right before me lies and
Lord Jesus
God is good what is that noise that's
the sound Awards being decimated by God
dude this world is so [__] up like I
mean this guy's real like this is a real
guy that's unbelievable it's the blood
of God that's right it's a blood of God
mate
yeah all right congratulations Lena
we're free since uh
like 2006 or something yeah thank you
you know just real quick one other time
where Lena was healed with some black
magic was by Sam
when we were actually we were leaving
Dan's apartment I forgot what we were
doing there um and Lena
she kept sneezing and then Sam said
when's uh would you what does it say it
was hiccups hiccups sorry hiccups yes
hiccups go ahead
and I asked Lena when is the last time
you saw a rabbit oh that is some black
magic [__] because that and they went
away literally all night long God them
hiccups is a curse from the underworld
favorite Bunny Man
every time a man touch another man's
penis a hiccup is born in the poor
defense of his child Brit Bunny Man
Lord help me
are you are you a witch Sam
[__] brother I might be oh that's a good
southern accent yeah she's a good old
girl I was just there for a month it's
really I've been working on it listen
but let me hear that good southern
accent
yeah
say I'm gonna have a barbecue and eat
some cornbread also or no say this say
this the God I can't just you can't it
just comes naturally yeah because you
you'll forget Sam's a good old southern
girl she's a southern belle out from uh
them Georgia George
that's the most wet trash State there is
boy I don't disrespect Mississippi like
that they only have one thing with peace
and love of course
what y'all need out there in Georgia
uh uh shrimp and grits shrimp and grits
that's a God oh God said good to trip
and grits
all right
thank you
we have made it zero percent way through
our planned show today
[Music]
oh yeah y'all want some Shredder updates
I'll be quick but did I talk about his
good blood results on the show or
thinking no because I think you got the
news right after the show on Friday
yes so um
this week
Shredder
has been awesome he is like doing so
good
he's eating his kidney food you know
shredders like notoriously picky eater
and he's eating the kibble approved
kidney approves he's eating he's
drinking we don't even have to give him
um
uh
the fluids anymore
that's great he's finishing his
antibiotics so
we got the test back actually here I can
show it um can you try to find the
picture I can show it it's kind of
interesting of the vet the vet sent me
a breakdown of his blood levels
and it was a remarkable decrease in
toxins although I have I'm just I'm
being cautiously optimistic here because
he went from like total stage four
kidney failure like he should be dead to
stage three kidney failure so like his
levels are still really bad but a lot
better and hopefully based on his
behavior because he's he's been in such
a good mood his energy levels are
awesome he's just great
that it's going to keep going down I
just I hope and I Jesus please God save
my dog Lord help me
yes people are people were upset that I
violated Shredder's hippo rights
and I do apologize uh for that
here it is
private info on it
I did get a shredder did do a paw I
stamped his paw with ink so this is
he gave me the all clear oh here I'll
pull it up right here for now because
apparently your laptop's having a
connection issue but here it is
okay she said I just got some initial
lab results and there's a significant
Improvement
and Shredder's kidney values I put them
on the table so we can track uh the
levels the Improvement was pretty
impressive she said and it's on the
downward Trend and hopefully on the way
to recovery
yeah so the creatine I guess is like the
main marker for Kidney Health and six is
anything over like uh the normal range
on this side yeah any I was I've been
reading about it like Non-Stop and
trying to understand what the [__]
going on anything over like a 5.5 is
like straight up on you're gonna die at
any minute kidney failure so he was
catastrophic on that and 3.5 where he
was at last week we're going to do
another test tomorrow is stage three
kidney failure which is really bad but
obviously
not as bad as it was
and these BUN levels look at this [__]
the normal range is 9 to 30 he was at
191 like crazy
wow
it's a lot of buns that's a lot of buns
I don't know I don't remember what that
one is
she said these two in the middle were
less important than creatine and
phosphorus
and the phosphorus is almost almost down
to normal
yeah and I have like a phosphorus binder
I don't know how I'm going to get them
to eat this powder but it's it it binds
with phosphorus and lowers it so that's
cool that's good so maybe doing that
tonight
so
gosh I don't know you know I'm being
cautiously optimistic I don't know where
his levels are going to stop
there's a chance that he doesn't even
have
kidney disease and he just had an acute
kidney failure from eating something and
went into like kidney failure
so she she says there's a chance that it
can all go down to normal levels but I
I'm being very cautious because all last
I mean all last week I was just bawling
my eyes out having like existential
crisis because my dog was gonna [__]
die and the Vets who treated him were
like now your dog's gonna die your dog
is I mean Lena you talk to them how
Bleak were those [__] yeah yeah they
were unbelievable and I I feel like
maybe they were just really busy and
that's why they kept like kind of just
trying to brush me off
and we're being very helpful
yeah but
I guess his levels were really bad and
you know 50 over 50 percent of animals
with that level of kidney disease just
die they don't make it
so Shredder is doing great it's all it's
honestly miraculous Jesus Lord help me
I feel like I wonder if I wonder if they
err on the side of like bad they do it's
worse yeah they do I mean I guess it's
good because you don't want to want it
to be the other way around for them to
say it's fine and then something
horrible happens a hundred percent they
do yeah and my expectations were
basically at zero so
yeah that's not good either obviously
but um yeah the vet said he's not he's
hydrated he's hasn't lost too much
weight he looks good
his finals are all good so we don't have
to even stick him with that needle to
give him fluids anymore
so here's just hoping for the best but
um
it's crazy
yeah I don't know those vets were so
like they they it's just the way they
spoke us about stuff with such certainty
they're like he has chronic and acute
kidney disease
and my vet now that I have
who I'm actually able to talk with is
like there's no way to know if he has
chronic kidney disease unless we track
it for a while and see where his levels
are
so I don't know the ones at the hospital
were really [__] maybe oh God you
know we need to get that witchcraft lady
out there
because science is just not not cutting
it it's not good we need the Lebanese
eggplant lady for sure I'll track her
down for you guys I'm gonna bring home
an eggplant for you child
eat this eggplant
um
but I'm actually scared because so he
had an acute failure which means he ate
like a grape
a raisin
some kind of apparently like uh
ibuprofen can do that a rat poison I
don't know what he could have eaten that
almost killed him
from kidney failure and I'm scared that
the threat is still out there
you know I talked to the gardeners I
talk we have like pest people I talked
to them they all say they don't use
anything toxic
foreign
but some of y'all don't know this but
grapes and raisins will can kill your
dog immediately like y'all really gotta
know that
because most people don't know that most
people think it's chocolate and
chocolate will make them sick but I
don't think it will give them kidney
disease like one grape
can cause kidney failure one great
so y'all be careful and I by the way
I've had a ban
on raisins and grapes in the house ban
no none allowed I don't let anyone to
eat that [__]
so people are saying milk we we don't I
don't actually have milkweed in the
backyard sorry
[Music]
um
I have to help myself
yikes but you know it's weird Shredder's
not like it doesn't eat [__] off the
ground randomly like he's just he's not
one of those dogs he's too picky for
that yeah they're a sweetener um Xylitol
can kill a dog
what what it could have been Xylitol
like what does that end is I I don't
think that's widely used Isla tall it's
an artificial sweetener and it can cause
a media kidney failure this ship
oh I I had a vet who was my neighbor at
my last house awesome nice guy we used
to chat a lot and he said this one
Xylitol it just kills dogs like no shot
dead
like what what items is this used in
the second result is about how it kills
dogs
look at that oh and gums
let's see Xylitol products because I
usually it's aspartame whenever I look
so what products are made from Xylitol
toothpaste mouthwash chewing gum
peanut butter peanut butter
he didn't he doesn't have I mean there I
don't see how he could have had peanut
butter
but please stop using this ingredient
all you [__] out there
fruit drinks jellies cereals baked goods
sugar-free pudding
[__] I wonder if it could be that it
could be any one of those [__] things
also it could have been that he had a
bladder infection that went up to his
kidney that's the other option and
that's why he's on a bunch of
antibiotics right now just in case
yo I gotta go see if there's Xylitol in
any of my [__] but yeah a lot of this
stuff that's actually super deadly to
your dog I feel like people don't know
about it as much
[__]
but anyway he's doing good
and uh we're gonna test his blood
tomorrow and I'll keep you guys updated
but God damn
protect your animals
scary out there
so there it is
also
um
let's move on here Jimmy was banned on
Instagram but he got it back so whatever
not that interesting I guess
I figured Jimmy got banned for botting
all different things my assumption but
he's back so
how did Jimmy get Instagram to respond
Instagram don't respond to anything
flavors well he has a big he has 200 000
followers he's back with 200k it could
be the service that he bought the Bots
from could have held his account hostage
for a certain amount
they do that sometimes because you know
what dude I think it was something like
that because when you visit it wasn't
like
some punitive thing it was just like
somebody hid the account flavors can did
you ask him was he held hostage or
something
um according to him I didn't hear
anything about held hostage
um as far as the Bots go he said it was
uh not him but someone on his team uh
Joey Joey Palazzo oh dude
so Jimmy was panicking and emailing me
all weekend uh I have never responded to
one of his emails ever
but I guess he knows I read them
different flavors so he sent me an email
um
asking if I have a contact at Instagram
and as Ian knows
I don't really
but he sent me an email from a new Alias
so he was emailing me from Jimmy Lee
Stevie Ross and then I got one from a
new guy can we show this yeah yeah
please oh we'll just just don't show his
emails yeah it doesn't say it anywhere
check it out I got one from Joey Del
paldozo Del Palazzo
it's me Joey Del Palazzo we tried to
come up with the most Italian sounding
name he possibly could hey but he
doesn't even pretend he's just like it's
Jimmy Jimmy I think he thinks I like the
double uh sent from my iPhone send off
there wait why does it do that why does
he get two of them probably copy pasted
the same email oh oh yeah
I think he thinks if he sends it from a
new name maybe I'll think it's something
interesting and look at it who's Joey
Del Palazzo I think that's his PR guy
he's got Steve Ross manager he's got
Joey the pr guy
I've got all different flavors of PR
guys different flavors so that's the guy
that uh bought the Bots for him
yeah Joey Del bazzo actually you know I
missed this screenshot that's exactly
what happened he had to put in his login
to buy those followers and then they
took his his account can we ask him I
want to know what happened he will not
tell us the truth he will die on a
pedestal for this one yeah I I can try
to get out of him Jimmy's an honest guy
he'll be honest with them not when it
comes to this [__] man he just he asked
him how he got his account that means an
honest guy he's lied to her face so many
times really about what his age his age
well but that that's how many fans he
has the fact that he's not buying Bots
who he voted for president who he voted
for President the fact that he's not
Steve Rossi yeah should I keep going is
that not enough I just text him how did
you get your account back it's not
enough Jimmy
one of the girls who made who I made an
article with on secret La actually
emailed me the day after we talked about
it and said that Steve Rossi emailed her
um
Steve Rossi the best manager in the game
wait he's really paying attention yeah
she said the devil Works harder but
Steve Rossi works
right so Steve Rossi reached I was like
hey I've got this guy
Jimmy Lee you want to do a write-up so
yeah do you live in L.A he's like no I
live in New Jersey so I attacked
somebody he responded instantly by the
way I said how'd you get your account
back he's all trying I said it's back he
said I know can't get an app to post
Ethan help question mark
what Ethan help help him I don't
understand anything you just said I I
think AB might be right they're holding
it hostage well if that's the case this
tell we can you know
let's get the story because this is
compelling stuff
happy birthday ashtay
we love you
Pharisee thank you so much for the Dono
Pharisees see
yeah if I'd love to chat I know y'all
hate when Jimmy Lee calls but like dude
this guy is just chock full of
interesting [__]
you know yep
I'll keep it short I promise if he calls
in I'll keep it really short well before
we get to any of that
we have a scheduled call in today and
we're coming up on the time so maybe we
can uh start setting that up
oh yeah Nick Accardo responded to us by
the way on his podcast too apparently
it's funny I haven't seen it
yeah let's set it up and can't while you
set that up
um
we're having this guy who I've been
following on Tick Tock super interesting
guy his name is John Buckley have any of
you guys come across his videos I am a
major fan I've seen every video of his
well yeah he's such a character and like
he knows everything about watches this
guy like buys and sells watches
and he films these like hardcore
negotiations he does with the watch
people
and uh so compelling here but we are
here with Leah fan favorite at Color
Couture
on the street and I see
got it how much is the rainbow that
rainbow runs from 100 and ten thousand
dollars and may I also see the sub he
just buys and sells a hundred thousand
dollar watches whoa
this one right here
thank you got a nice watch that this one
that one's 38 gorgeous watch does this
have a card yes boxing papers police set
okay and this also yes boxing papers and
this is 110. everything Factory
[Music]
let me let me hold off on this one this
over here
it's got a card in a box full links
Everything full lengths 34 000. 30
yeah that's crazy 34.5
[Music]
I'm getting there yeah I'm getting close
it's got links which is nice yeah yeah
I I don't know I me too I put it on I
just watched the whole video every time
so what it fascinates about you just
because you're not like I don't care
about watches at all right but you're
not at all so he's super interesting
funny character
and the watches are actually really
beautiful that he he like I've never
like that I mean I don't care about
watching over 100 Grand yeah yeah and I
don't know it's interesting how they
negotiate it's [__] crazy here I mean
you get down to the nitty gritty here
it's a v cereal I like the older one I
like the color on this one better
[Music]
you ready here we go you ready are you
ready maybe all right 35
000 is off 35 30 38 yeah
[Music]
you're going to pull the trigger
I know you can you think I can I think
you can let me verify it I'm I'll I'll
pay 35 I'll write you check or I'll send
you wire right now we'll wirele it
tomorrow morning 35 balloons check now
or a wire in the morning
I could never say no to you
my guy the camaraderie
they always come to a deal at the end
such Joy muzzle I [__] love that [__]
dude it's just it's good old New York
jewelry [__] oh [__] Sophie said I'm the
girl from Secret L.A I got eight emails
from Steve Rossi
that's awesome Steve Rossi
Jimmy and he probably does that to all
all the people we were talking about
he's a hustler man he's a natural born
Hustler
the only problem is he's not a good
comedian but if he was Boy he'd be going
places
oh yeah
so there it is that's John Buckley the
legendary Watchman
um
and his videos are pretty popular I'm
not the only one but I mean do you guys
just not is it
you know what I mean is this just not
something this is what I do
okay I'm gonna tell him what's wrong
with the watch watch I like this I think
it's all correct and I will tell you why
did links are for a day chest
that's number one there's no 50 on the
end if it's a GMT it should have fifty
five zero right on this end piece right
here
okay watch itself
and look what you're calling it out his
face yeah yeah yeah no he's dude he's
insanely like knowledgeable not the
worst thing in the world but it's
definitely
correct
Little Switzerland people don't like
them but they're correct
you know everybody gives a heart they
used to make this 100
paper
this is everything's good yeah it's a
nice watch I don't know 10 12 Grand like
that
he has Crown oh there you go
nice dial though beautiful nice
style get a get a good band because a
guy like me who's going to spend all the
money on something like this is going to
complain about the band
this band is band is not original
13. I bought this like eight months ago
okay and there's nothing else wrong with
it it's a nice nice watch inserts a
little rough but it's original and it's
fat font it's nice yeah that sounds fine
that's fine yeah no issues let's see
something
yeah your hands are glowing is that good
no later hands it's better for them not
to Glow yeah it's later hands but listen
it's a nice watch it's a real nice watch
it's a nice watch he's got the bracelet
you need a GMT bracelet you got the end
pieces the end pieces are right there is
one himself too he what he like repairs
watches and changes he does yeah oh no
he's insane dude actually I do want to
he's in the lobby I just need to pee
real fast I don't want to get stuck with
this uh bag of urine
this bag a year emptying this I gotta
get you a [__] catheter or something
a catheter would I hear people
some people like that
sounding a little sounding yeah
all right I'll be right back whoa I like
that song The Point did you just play
that no but I like it no that Zach just
played it yeah it was me that's the
Roblox oof yeah I know yeah let's go do
you guys know about the video that that
YouTuber made the like two-hour
documentary about the uh the origin of
that sound effect
so there's a uh there's a YouTuber I've
been following for a long time his name
is H H bomber guy
and uh
you know he's sometimes political but a
lot of them a lot of the videos that he
makes are just like these video essays
about random [__] and he decided to try
and track down the origin of that sound
effect because it's such a meme it's
like you hear it in [__] Tick Tock
videos and all that [__] all the time
and it turns into like a two hour
documentary where he goes down this
insane rabbit hole and meets this
lunatic who like owns it and was like
suing the ROBLOX Corporation to try and
get them to pay him because it was
originally from one of his video games
in the 90s but he didn't really design
it and so there was like this whole back
and forth
I know that sounds very weird it is the
most interesting YouTube video on a
sound effect that I have ever seen and I
thought that's a huge I definitely watch
that it's actually it's it's really
[__] good content I don't want to
spoil I'm trying to like tiptoe around
it because it has like some twists that
you would never [__] expect from a
video about a Roblox sound effect
yeah I see some people in the chat are
familiar with them yeah those are great
to get this all the time but he kind of
looks like you then
oh the H bomber guy
let me see
shot shot he doesn't have a beard though
oh that's one thing oh in that video he
kind of does yeah a little bit
HB word guy
[Laughter]
[Music]
Roblox lore let's go wow it seems like a
lot of people yeah people are talking
about the guy Tommy talarico dude the
video is so good Tommy tariko's in it
that's who the video is about you're
familiar with him I met him once yeah no
way yeah I met him once he uh he was the
conductor of like video games live
that's right he sure is yeah okay wow he
used to be big on G4 too he he is the
main character of this video that I'm
talking about
well I'll take any Dan recommend
recommendation as gospel so I'll
definitely watching this later
just like Avatar 2.
which I watched yesterday and it was
great
all right the first
okay one second let me bring the buck
and I'm gonna let him in
love I like that you got your uh your
Zoomer [__]
screen oh yeah
oh that's awesome
don't get distracted because uh I'm
letting in uh John here right now
one second
and that's so fine
Zoomers are so [__] dude
hey come on now we're trying our best oh
all right here we go
there he is in his underground bunker
with all the watches
in the grow room
John Buckley hello thanks for calling in
nice to meet you
hey nice to meet you too you can almost
call me Jeff
I did not don't say that
I didn't nope I refused that where are
you right now
what's that where are you right
nobody you're it seems like you're you
know is was there a nuclear bomb drop or
something that I missed not yet not yet
things like uh
the humidity has to be a certain level
so that things don't uh you know rot so
the radium doesn't kill us faster than
it normally does
so let's see oh is that a weed growing
room somebody said are you also doing
that oh definitely not
it's not poking weed about 30 years ago
well unfortunately you you've um you've
built such an interesting kind of
profile for yourself online on tick tock
and I've become a fan of yours I love
watching your videos great and um
I find it so interesting
how do you how is it that you uh like
what what is your business because I
noticed sometimes you go and you're
looking for a specific watch do you have
clients who are like I want this watch
go find it or how does that work
well I deal with probably
I usually say there's a dozen people
that I deal with like on a daily basis
and a lot of times I've got guys that
I've known for the better part of 20
years that call me up and they're like
okay Buckley I need uh this watch I need
a paddock 30 3970 or I need uh you know
a gold Daytona or I need a you know an
AP or this this and that and most of
these people I have you know a very very
long-standing relationship so they'll
either you know wire me up front or I'll
lay out money for them and then they'll
wire me when they hit town you know
usually they hit town within a couple of
days because these things are usually
but sometimes you know they'll come in a
week later or something like that but
I'm usually filling orders for people
sometimes I'll stock stuff I mean I
stocked um there was a video
oh wow a couple months ago you may
remember it if you're one of these guys
that likes to watch the videos I kind of
like to watch them too they're kind of
interesting like just from you know from
my perspective I like to watch them and
kind of see what I'm doing wrong and
doing right but we do everything live
and I never edit I never cut I always do
things in one take and we did a
um a watch that I bought actually that I
still have I don't have it here I've got
it locked up in the city but um the Hans
willsdorf
um the own the founder of Rolex is watch
to somebody you know like 60 years 70
years ago or something like that and
I've been trying to buy it for like 10
years off the owner and then the owner
got uh rest in peace he passed away and
I wound up buying it from the estate and
that was the video so you waited for
this so This dude had to die before you
would before you could get the watch now
now let me ask you this John did the
police have any questions for you
knowing you had a motive did you know
something I had a really good Alibi I'm
from Brooklyn so I think ahead okay okay
good you got receipts from yeah good
yeah you know like an Easy Pass uh
tickets and things like that
so yeah so how much was that watched I I
wound up paying 125 for it 125 Grand
yeah and uh I've been trying to buy it
since it was like 50 or 60. that's you
know that's how these things work
sometimes you know you really have to be
I'm not that much of a collector okay I
I am kind of I'm what I like to consider
a professional collector I mean I buy
and sell for money okay I the passion
has kind of left left me years ago for
this stuff and a lot of people don't
understand that you know they they
wonder why it is that I'll wear an Apple
Watch and you know I'm going out there
buying all of these crazy watches and
it's just you know I remember years ago
when and sometimes guys don't understand
when I say that it used to be really
special to be involved in you know
horology or vintage watches especially
that's my that's my area of expertise
and there were maybe you know 100 or 200
of us you know back in the late 90s
early 2000s that used to do this and you
know now it's like every Tom Dick and
Harry you know dealer on 47th Street
fancies themselves a vintage guy and you
know it just kind of rubs me the wrong
way like because they don't you think
that they don't have the credentials oh
they don't yes I have the credentials
yeah
it's like classic cars you know and I'm
not a car guy but I know there are guys
that you know can look at a car from a
mile away you know and they'll know that
that's the original bumper those are the
original tires like I'm the same way
when it comes to this stuff so wait how
is it that you make money you buy just a
resell at a markup or
edgy that stuff more as a courtesy to my
my long-standing customers I'm a parts I
I deal in Parts I deal in investment
grade watches and investment grade Parts
like some of those why most of the
watches that I buy and sell on Tick Tock
are you know for the most part they're
modern watches but when you get into
like the older vintage stuff from the
50s 60s 70s 80s there are very specific
parts that go with them and I'm an
expert at identifying those parts in
like you know a bag of other parts and
I'll know there's one part that I can
use that I could sell to my customer in
Singapore who's you know waiting to put
together this watch that's going to be
worth you know mid six figure watch and
all I had to sell them this one little
part that I'll get I don't know 50 or 60
grand for and I'll be happy today and
that's correct so you have the really
interesting specialty uh skill so what's
the most you've paid for a watch
oh man I I've I've partnered on seven
figure watches I've bought six figure
watches I mean I buy them six figure
watches regularly on Tick Tock but is
that is that for you to how many of
those do you keep do you do you keep
them or you you sell them
I still have the the one from the estate
I I have that one I wanted that one you
know most of the time I'm just filling
an order for somebody and I you know I
do it because a I make money B I'm
already there it's really not a lot of
work you know it's just writing a check
or sending a wire and people I don't
know what it is about the younger
generation I'm 59 I just turned 59 last
week and people are like how are you
still writing checks and what guys don't
understand is you know to send a bank
what you can't do a Zell or a credit
card nobody you know in my business
we're wholesalers Nobody Does that you
have to either send a wire or write a
check and if you send a wire a wire
costs you thirty dollars in thirty
dollars out so if I do that 10 times a
week times four I mean you know it comes
out to a you know substantial amount of
money every month so that's right back
and the people that we work with I mean
we have relationships with them I mean
you know you see some of the guys little
Eddie and Albert Yasha
um Leah yeah I can call it Couture and
Leah and Bobby is
I mean those are friends for you know
over 20 years does anyone ever uh stiff
you you say that like people you buy it
for them so you put out money as they
won't ever stiff you
every once in a while I just I got burnt
not burnt I mean look you know I I tell
people this and they look at me like I'm
crazy I lose money on probably between
five and ten percent of everything that
I buy now I'm speaking about parts and
stuff like that but like a month and a
half ago I had a customer that you know
called me up wanted a um a green dial
Daytona it was like I forget what I
think I paid 82 000 for it he was
supposed to give me 83 he was flying in
the next day guy just ghosted me after
that I wound up selling the watch back
to who I bought it off I've lost about
six or seven thousand dollars on the
deal in a couple of days I was but this
is the business you know there are other
days that I make that you know three
four five times over so you know you cry
over it if you're a dealer you know I
mean I'm a veteran dealer so this stuff
I mean you lose money sometime just the
way it is but we make more than we lose
yeah Zach you got any questions are show
them your watch Zach let's see let's get
a read on it's a black date sub I think
the reference number is 11 66 10 Ln is
the model number is that helpful to you
the model number
yeah that's the model number okay that's
good okay I beautiful watch yeah
beautiful thank you thank you beautiful
watch I mean the classic Rolex
John Buckley I love the video of the one
uh it was for these Secret Service I
believe that that black sub
oh you don't know the story behind that
oh there's a story behind it go go look
for the video now
yeah you know I I I'm not a watch guy
but I'd be afraid of getting mugged on
the street with a watch like that
expensive you know does that happen
not not to us maybe other people it does
because oh you know what
we are very careful I grew up in the
city I grew up in New York in the 70s so
you know I'm no babe in the woods we
have you know we are you know well
protected and we have security that's
the work or you know around on the Block
we're safe other guys you know that's
why we don't go around and we don't
flash and we don't take things off the
street really I mean we have evolved on
the street we get to the street we get
our stuff we run around 47th Street and
the street is very safe okay and we
still you know I mean obviously we carry
protection but I mean you know we carry
sometimes we have somebody with us
sometimes we have people in the building
that are looking out but never you know
we don't take stuff I mean I'll ship
stuff many times to the office in New
Jersey you know I'm not going to carry
it you know across in a car you know
where you know God forbid you get into a
car accident or something like that you
lose you know two hundred thousand
dollars which is you know we're veterans
you know I've been doing this a long
time I know all the pitfalls I've seen
guys you know get hurt out there and
killed really
bad yeah getting mugged like killed how
oh I have a friend that um he was
leaving a trade show and he was on the
um Garden State Parkway in a taxi cab
and one of the car and R pushed him off
the road in the taxi cab whoa jump shot
him through the face and stole his back
he's alive
yeah all right the guy's alive he lived
I mean they weren't how much did he lose
a couple hundred thousand yeah
that's crazy here's the problem it's
like if I'm doing a trade show I'm
shipping you know armored car
um from secure location to a secure
location from 47
to the trade show you know where there's
a safe room with you know armed guards
all over the place do the show and then
you ship it back you don't carry your
stuff out of the show it's just not what
you do right you know you know what they
don't want to spend the extra thousand
fifteen hundred each way to do that I
mean we you know we don't we don't we
don't play like that you know I have
myself
you know I have Tyler with us you know
and it's like we you know we're careful
you know I can't take chances like that
do you recommend Zach uh be strapped
he's wearing a classic Rolex he walks
around La City with that on that got
that display of wealth do you think he
needs some protection
it's not a question of needing some
protection it's a question of being
really careful when you're at a
restaurant and you have a couple of
drinks in you oh yeah
if you look on Tick Tock I think the
tick tock stolen watches or something
like that and you'll see all the I mean
I get these videos before they go online
because customers will send them to me
and say hey I'm not wearing my uh you
know my Paddock 5980 or something like
that you know and I'll be like yeah good
you should be wearing that you know
walking around Barcelona or you know
walking through the Streets of London
London is really bad lately so Zach are
you looking over your shoulder now that
you're kind of a Rolex guy how's that
changed your perspective on the street I
won't wear it everywhere okay where
won't you wear it
um
usually if it's like I'm going to hang
out with friends or something and we
know we're going out to dinner I
probably won't wear it then I just I
wear it in places I know that are
comfortable the John Buckley experience
Zach he's already a veteran he's learned
you know be careful listen it's a new
world there were times listen I have
stories you know I I've walked through
you know
the the streets of Milan alone wearing
you know expensive watches and you know
I like to collect World Series rings and
you know I'd be walking around with
Yankees World Series ring and a Rolex
Daytona on my on my life where World
Series ring
you can't oh yeah I don't think you're
allowed to do that John
I collected will you wear it oh yeah
people mistake that's like baseball
players did what did you ever pretend
you were a Yankee yeah you ever does it
ever work for you at the bar oh wait I
was in mastros about in Vegas that's a
bit of Stolen Valor there John I have to
say you're familiar with that concept
listen I'm in Masters I got a Lakers
championship ring on each hand what why
that's crazy what the hell
rings
and there's this couple sitting next to
me and they were looking at me you know
it was an old black couple and they're
looking at me and I'm sitting there and
I'm eating my whatever I was eating and
I was with one of my guys and I get up
and the lady she was very sweet she was
like excuse me sir what is the
significance of those rings so I'm like
oh these are from the Los Angeles Lakers
uh you know 2010 and 2011 or I forget
the years that they were and it's like
oh are you on the team I was like yes I
was she was like Magic Johnson she was
like oh what a pleasure to meet you
how tall are you John I can't tell with
you
dude I gotta say that's kind of wild to
walk around in those Rings like that's
like wearing that's like wearing a high
school graduation ring from a different
Harbor grad yeah yeah that's funny
though that's funny business and I get
all of this stuff I mean people know
that I collect this stuff I mean I've
got NYU rings I mean I don't wear that
stuff I don't care about NYU but I mean
I'll wear a Yankees ring I mean I'll be
in Newark Airport and somebody will walk
up to me like oh wow can I take a
picture with you who are you I'm like oh
Joe Torrey they're like oh wow wait so
how much does the does a championship
ring cost they they could they range I
mean from a stat of a top level staff
ring which is the same ring that a
player would get like a front office a
real front office guy probably 30 grand
and to a player I mean you can go I mean
hundreds of thousands do you know who do
you know whose Rings they were and
at a high level staff friend and it was
okay okay
I think I have it upstairs and um it's
just one of those things where I just I
I really like it I mean when I stopped
when I kind of like stopped with the
watches like being really passionate
about them I mean look I was one of
these guys that I would go on vacation I
mean I have pictures in Jamaica at duns
River Falls wearing you know a freaking
Diamond GMT and I'm like walking around
like this you guys running up to me like
trying to sell me uh aloe and uh beads
and stuff like that and I was like nah
it's not a good idea no you know but uh
the World Series rings are fun so let me
ask you this how much is your whole
collection worth are you comfortable
saying I don't care like much of a
collection I mean my ring collection six
figures at least I mean my watch
collection I don't really have that many
watches that I collect per stay I've got
first Rolex I ever owned I have maybe
like three or four other watches that uh
you know that I really like but I mean
I'm not really like you know it's just
collected them over the years but my
first Rolex I still have my son who who
shoots the videos he wears it all the
time and I don't like her son that's
nice do you have any ice out there that
you could bust out for us I want to see
John all like pimped out
uh I don't have any ice here I had a
University of North Carolina like that I
was wearing in a video the other day see
me I'm one of these guys I like this
kind of stuff this is like I'm in the
lab now so this is the kind of stuff I
like like a wow what do you think oh
those are all dials okay what's what's
each one of those run if you were to
sell it
I mean I don't know like if somebody
offered me you know 100 grand for the
tray I'd say no well
damn
it's that's the kind of stuff that moves
more you know I want John I want
something like this can we set this up I
don't know if maybe next time I call or
something
can you see this photo
I can't I've got Buck can you my son's
over there being producer he's uh yeah
he's holding pictures of like what does
he have wait he's gonna show me on his
phone
oh wait he's refreshing hold on oh my
god oh there's a picture of you with
like championship rings with like like
photoshopped on your head I like this
really yeah yeah that's what I'd like to
see maybe uh next time there but uh
but there it is where let me see wait no
I'm oh you can't see it you can't see it
we're having production I mean uh
technical difficulties over here you
know I I personally the watch thing
it's like like you guys say you have to
be so scared or apprehensive going
everywhere it seems like more of a pain
but I guess you gotta flash it right
Zach you gotta let the people know well
that's not what it's about for me I
think what about is the history and the
craftsmanship of it more than a flash
piece I guess we will so is Zach like a
new watch lover is he a horology guy
what do you like
prove your exactly yeah what's your
credential here Zach I mean my my
I've been obsessed with watches probably
since I was I don't know 16 and my dad
had Rolexes and
um you know I'd love a next watch is a
panda you know or a um yeah or uh you
know the I daytonas are coming down in
price so I'd really
yeah there you know it's it's weird I've
been through many a market crash over
the years since the 90s and you know it
boggles the mind that folks look at an
up market like we've had in the last two
years and think it's never gonna end and
the funny thing is like we as dealers
like a lot of dealers I mean we make a
lot of money you know as the Market's
going up and you know people are not
fair with others you know I always get
the call from somebody who bought
something from another dealer and
they'll be like oh you know I need to
sell this I just paid like 50 grand for
it I'm like well you know I could sell
it to you for 30 now you know what would
you like me to do you know and I'd be
like well why don't you go back and talk
to the person who sold it to you and
they're always like oh well you're
buying right now I'm like yeah well
that's that's really not cool you know
let me ask you uh let me ask you
something
are you familiar with Dave Portnoy you
know who that is
absolutely yeah okay cool another New
Yorker right he made this he made this
watch company called brick watch company
have you seen this
yeah would you like my take on it I
would absolutely love your honest
opinion on this and they're not cheap
right I mean they're pretty like this
one right here is 2500 bucks so that's
it yeah go ahead please tell me
everything
nothing but respect for Dave Portmore
he's actually he's friends with uh I
don't think that's his he's he's
buttering us up oh okay yeah
could be really blunt okay I know he's a
really good guy he looks at I have a
friend down here who owns a pizza store
uh Brooklyn Square we don't even we
don't even like him here so you don't
have to worry about like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you don't have to worry these are
these are direct competition yeah all
right well one thing that I could say
about whoever was spearheading that they
were not watch people because what they
they tried to push a fashion watch into
like a mid-level watch Market with no
branding and no real provenance the
problem with that watch was that it's
2500 bucks probably cost you a hundred
bucks to produce and then another 100 to
Market so if they would have sold that
watch in like the five six seven hundred
dollar range they would have sold a
boatload of them okay but whatever was
was advising him on this or advising the
company I don't think he had really very
much input he did an interview mine just
recently and it you know it's like he
wasn't really advised properly Whoever
thought of this was just looking for a
money grab and thought that you know
just because it's you know a bar stool
you know that he would uh he would be
funny and so there it is uh John Buckley
calling Dave Portnoy a money grab
sellout no I called I called his company
the money bro okay
you know I was on Barstool recently and
you know I mean it was it was a nice
experience I mean they were very he was
he was you know it was like you talked
with him okay okay no [__] it's some
other guy a guy named Doug's who found
me somewhere I mean we had like I don't
know two or three hundred thousand
followers on but I mean the thing with
the watch the Portnoy watch it's it's
just sad because they could have made
something that made a lot of money it's
just they didn't think it through and
they didn't consult anybody who really
knows the market the name the name of it
is Brick
which is kind of funny because that's
what you call an electronic that stops
working a brick right it's bricked you
guys are from my generation remember
when they named Led Zeppelin they said
it would go down like a lead balloon and
look at LEDs up okay so there you go
here close enough wait here's the return
policy let's see
yeah
uh if our product rubs damaged
wait why'd you send me this because it
seems like there's no returns there's
only store credit
if you buy one of the watches
oh if you like to change your watch for
stories it's a little yeah I think
you're right no returns huh that's not
cool that's not cool at all Dave Portnoy
we're calling you out uh why do you guys
what do you guys have a good day I'm
just kidding I'm just kidding I'm just I
like I like this third [__] I'm just
being a punk he's our direct competition
so we we have yeah but just so you know
well you so you
know I'm just I'm just a shitster it's
nothing personal okay I'm just being a
punk I'll help you start [__] look at
the people okay that are doing exactly
what I'm doing in such a high production
just ridiculously fake way all over the
internet now I mean we started this I
mean I'm partners in vukum okay and that
started vucum started this in the summer
before I even started doing Tick Tock
doing negotiations he and my son who ran
to jiu jitsu right now so I'm on my own
okay that shows you where I'm at over
here they started doing the negotiations
like in the late summer and they were
approached to do a tick tock show called
it's called buying time and we wound up
doing the Show recently after I got into
it and now you got every Tom Dick and
Harry out there going over there hey how
much is this watch oh I'll buy it for
one thousand dollars no I want one
thousand two hundred and fifty dollars
and it's just so forced and just so
almost cringy yeah
look you're the only real one out there
John you're a Trailblazer and I wish
everybody else nothing but the worst
and for you John only the best but I
appreciate you chatting with us it was
nice to get to know you
congratulations on a really cool
interesting career and also so cool that
you're able to share it with uh with the
people of the world so very cool I
really I wanted to say I really
appreciate you getting me on here I know
it's a big deal because every time I was
like oh I'm doing this thing called H3 I
was like oh wow really I'm like yeah
we're kind of a big deal there's no it's
not it's not a problem this ain't no
small town stuff like bar stool yeah I
mean you know it's no problem though
it's all good
yeah but not as big time as you I mean
you're big you're in big you're big on
Tick Tock all right John
I was loving this stuff you know before
it got popular so it's it's just all
good to me I love it it's important that
everybody enjoys it and I'm glad you
guys are enjoying it too it's my
pleasure yeah I love it keep it up God
bless go get more of those Laker rings I
want I want a Laker championship ring on
every finger
you have me on next time I'll come over
here yes that'd be what I want you tell
me when you're ready and I and I want
that I want that I want the necklace I
want the watch I want the most expensive
you can put together all right do you
have a tiara or a crown or something
find it don't worry yeah you have
everything that sounds that sounds
awesome all right take care nice
chatting thank you
good day
interesting guy John Buckley
The Watch King oh wait love dang keep
love open for Stuff
yeah I don't know what it is but I'm
just really enjoying watching Love's
feed right now I got some soap cutting
some
um Surfer Subway Surfer yeah uh kinetic
sand we got some um What's this called
yeah that was freaking me out bro I
don't like that one I don't like it I
don't like it this one no the one okay
now it's better
the temple run it had it was on a menu
[Music]
all right thank you love I can watch
this all day but uh yeah yeah we got our
show too there you go John Buckley
um
Zach the legend you got respect from him
too he was a really cool guy I mean I
love his videos and I've learned a lot
from him watching his videos I was
hoping he was gonna [__] dunk on your
Rolex that you're saying I was kind of
hoping because I was wearing a real
moment it'd be like ah so get this
peasant [__] out of here yeah yeah
wait whoa whoa whoa that's crazy
speaking of Dave pork boy somebody said
selling they matched the return address
yeah they matched the return address for
Brick watches back to another company uh
that sell it American yeah and they sell
watches for 40 bucks yep
okay well okay it could just be like a
watch fulfillment center is that
possible or is it like if you Google it
is it their their address like what
American
let's see necklace
but I mean dude who's gonna buy a 2500
watch from Dave porknoy that's just the
weirdest thing ever
you know that's a lot of money
Aidan Ross is trending what'd you do now
do I need to sit down with you again
what the [__]
oh dude Aiden Ross I really gotta talk
to them twitch
and we're gonna get let's talk about
this next Aiden Ross has come out
against hot tub streams
it's misogynistic it's peddling in Sex
and he doesn't like it with that
that's his problem with it well we'll
watch it I'll let's watch it after this
um but Zach go ahead tell me what
happened with Jimmy Lee you you want me
to proceed with it like Okay
um so I heard from him
um I feel really bad
um I said
um
I said I think when you were purchasing
the followers uh someone is holding your
account hostage and he said it's not
them I was dumb someone offered me a
fake blue check mark it was someone else
but so someone did hijack but then how
did he get it back did he have to pay
them off or something I he I don't think
he knows what's going on I asked him if
he wants to call him please please oh
Jimmy we'll stop doing interesting stuff
because I don't necessarily want to keep
talking to you but I'm so interested in
what happened
um did he have to pay them off why would
they give it back to him he's not giving
me that detail
um he said not a good day for me to call
in once I restore okay not a good day
maybe Wednesday please upset I'm so
upset and I said I'm sorry you gotta be
careful I'm not that serious Jimmy if
you're watching Why by the way Jimmy's
working in someone's mouth and he's got
this open on the TV Jimmy it's not that
serious bro trust me it's like if you we
could make you a new account and get you
back to where you were in a second okay
don't feel bad it's just and also all
your followers are fake anyway so it's
fine you said I said you got to stop
buying followers he said okay I'm not
that person Zach it's someone else
and I said what person
I said and then he said let me know if
Ethan maybe knows someone on Instagram
uh I said I'll ask but what person are
you talking about please somebody's just
wasting their money give me leave follow
push I and then he said a hacker I don't
know Bush there's a hacker oh there's a
hacker they got they hacked me don't
push Zaki I got hacked well it was
hacked by uh Steve de Plaza what's his
name
Rossi yeah I Googled that name that's
apparently his Jackson Galaxy looking
goofball friend there who wears the
captain's hats oh that's his name that's
yeah that's Joey I guess wait it's a
real this is his friend Taylor's
friend's name Yeah well yeah Joey Joey
called in with him once that one time
wait why the [__] is he stealing his
homies
that's so weird Shakespearean play in
the making right now Jimmy you're doing
too much bro he's like just chill maybe
just spend time with your kids there's
some flavors like he told me he wants a
break yeah you need a
wait this is him feeling way too much
that's what that's what comes up when
you Google
oh no wonder they hang out he looks so
normal and he was at the restaurant with
them of course it looks like this yeah
it's the Jackson Galaxy looking guy he
looks like an ad for Just For Men hair
dye man this is a wild pick man he's on
the train track with a navy hat right
the Navy he's creating
fomo right there man hoorah
uh just hopefully he creates fomo
somewhere else when that train comes I
also I also Googled Steve Rossi who was
apparently a famous comedian back in the
day so he's just oh
I'm sorry
everything's got meaning with you man
everything's a secret nod hold it yeah
Jimmy please take a break you're doing
too much it's not that serious you're
upset trust me you don't have that much
time left just enjoy it with your family
and [__] you don't need to be straight
talk about it
he's like 31 years old or something yeah
he was in high school
1994.90s kid
I'm just saying Jimmy I'm just trying to
be honest with you yeah he why is he
wearing a Navy hat on a train track with
the it did okay all right I think he
goes on his other nickname for it goes
by the captain
that's that's what he calls him the
captain all right let's watch the maiden
raw stuff now let's get to some fun
stuff and this kid I'm telling you I
need to I need to Daddy him
as you guys know he's best friends with
Andrew Tate he talks about him lovingly
all the time it's embarrassing we'll see
now watch this
he comes out bravely against hot tub
streamers I'm gonna flat out and say it
bro we're gonna back me on this uh
twitch I believe heavily
um you know I saw one person that um
lost a lot of money to gambling you guys
banned gambling you guys moved on it
quick
I think we have a problem they did not
move on it quick just so no but just a
little annotation there not absolutely I
mean check your bank account how much
millions are in there from them not that
quick good for like a year and a half
two years yeah it's not quick no not at
all
you guys moved on it quick
I think we have a problem twitch I think
there's the hot tub streams bro I think
it's also like this is the oldest
discourse like the hot tub thing you
just I thought we were settled it's not
a big deal because I I don't want to
even say it you guys but this is why
it's important he is if he's this close
with Andrew Tate there's got to be some
misogyny leaking through why does he
care about hot tubs now let's hear his
reasoning move on to quick
I think we have a problem twitch I think
there's the hot tub streams bro I think
it's it should be banned from twitch I
think hot tub streaming should be banned
from twitch you're you know it's it's
it's it's soft porn uh it's a portal to
only fans so right off the bat I'm
wondering
what's wrong with that I guess if
they're kids but he doesn't mentioned
that I mean bro you sold gambling to
kids you have millions of dollars bro
you want to talk about a portal to only
fans and his Idol is a sex trafficker
but how is that like it doesn't need to
go any further than that you have a
problem with people with starting only
fans but you have no problem with but
sex trafficking what's funny is he's
acknowledging so he understands how like
this funnel works right and he doesn't
like it when women are benefiting
with their only fans but it's okay when
he makes millions of dollars sending
kids to go gamble an addictive [__]
Vice
it's such a weird take to come out with
now of all times and and you know it's
the same it's in the same category as
gambling right because it's it's
promoting poison uh you know dude his
brain is rotting out
his straight up brainwashed dude it's
crazy it's unsettling how
how brainwashed he is I think he is very
easily manipulated by people he that he
looks up to he clearly
the way that he just [__] simps for
Andrew Tate is not normal
and I don't even think it's a goof at
this point
um he's turning into like a puritanical
you'll see in some of his other takes
he's becoming like full Evangelical what
this takes it's weird right because it's
it's promoting poison uh you know what
I'm saying in the brain and it's it's
it's making people addicted to to uh
it's feeding their dude donate all the
money you made from gambling before you
[__] open your mouth on anything like
this
it's debatable right actually I totally
disagree that it's poison I mean some
some like hardcore porn stuff is poison
for sure
uh but but I don't think
doing and consuming uh whatever right we
can debate that but you gotta you gotta
return every dollar you made from
promoting gambling and something about
this house tells me you did not
okay
[__] their addiction to to jerking off
which is a serious problem we have okay
now you've gone too far bro
now I'm personally feeling attacked dude
so this is like part of the alpha
movement about I guess semen retention
or something or it's super weird good
thing about the gayest thing in the
world is being attracted to women for
these right it's they don't they believe
that jerking off is immoral no wonder
they're out there are wording everybody
if anything you guys need to be jerking
off more
right
I'm fro jerking off yeah please how many
times you jerk off today three double it
those are rookie numbers dude and jack
it off
this dude is so [__] dumb he's
actually getting boring now too that's
the he's not even funny he's just like
boring he's like I'm getting lectured by
this idiot this stupid [__] kid is
giving me some derivative red pill [__]
from like the worst people in the world
you don't know anything look how young
you are
stop dude
I'm 21. [__] you it's not old enough to
give life advice he's actually 22 now so
22 okay oh he's old if you are all right
he could tell me not to jerk off it's
poison
people it's so weird to to uh it's
feeding their addiction to to jerking
off which is a serious problem we have
how is that a serious problem
by the way jerking off for men actually
prevents cancer swear to God
it cleans the prostate it lowers your
chance of prostate cancer Google that
swear to God jerking off lower somebody
in the chat just said it too it's real
yeah I mean think about it if you're if
your [__] is just sitting there
it's gonna you know Donnie if there's
any toxins your body's gonna absorb it
if you're clearing it out all the time
you're getting the you know the fresh
spots aren't typically accurate that's
what's happening
the toxins just clearing out I'm saying
different things I'm seeing one article
says jerking off Cuts prostate cancer
risk by 33 yeah
no it's real I swear no I know it's real
it was just yours you're only gonna be
dropping dead a prostate cancer beat off
more jacket off I Really Wanna I really
want him to tell me how jerking off is
wrong
you know he jacks off like a [__]
fiend
I think he's actually not doing it I
think he's really committed this and
that's why he's so [__] crazy right
now so you think he's really really
invested dude he made a video
apologizing because he jerked off once
uh he and he's so sorry I let you guys
down wait where is that where is that is
that anything yeah yeah he he's a he is
he's not funny anymore he's just a weird
bro he's got a lot of poison in him that
he needs to get out you want to be Amish
or something go do it I don't understand
to uh it's feeding their addiction to to
jerking off which is a serious problem
we have it's not you know um I'm gonna
flat out say it I don't care who doesn't
agree but it's just a fact in my opinion
oh
that statement is contradictory awesome
quote in fact in my opinion yes
somebody needs to talk to this child get
over there dude I need to talk to this
child bring him when you go over and
pull up when you go over there bring a
big ass bottle of lotion you know just
be all here Aiden this is your ticket
out of it just go pull your pod go go
right now just go do it man
just [__] get that poison out of you
I just I this is so weird dude coming he
he's like somehow Gone full circle he's
not in a cold or part of well maybe he
is but usually people get all caught up
with the Bible or or the Torah Quran or
whatever religion that says jerking off
is bad this guy is just doing it just
[__]
well it flows down from there it still
is that same mindset is you know he's
Downstream of it and it's not directly
religious for him what is the argument
and against jerking off genuinely uh
Jesus is watching Jesus watching it
that's sin yeah so but what's his
argument I don't think he thinks Jesus
Andrew is watching Andrew is watching
boy save that nut for me
maybe that's why I'm saving it for when
Andrew gets out
a little weirdo yeah maybe we're being
like maybe we can be generous and say
like what he really means is like being
addicted to porn specifically no that's
not that's he was very specific he was
very specific yeah but we know that he's
not the most careful with his words so
it you're you know maybe he's talking
more like porn addictions only fans and
and you know it's the same it's in the
same category as gambling right because
it's it's promoting poison uh you know
what I'm saying in the brain and it's
it's it's making people addicted to to
uh it's feeding their addiction to to
jerking off which is
there's people jerking off on Twitch and
and I'm strictly against that
well I'm a jerk off to you Aiden you
can't stop me I mean I'm just what I'm
just saying you can't stop people from
jerking off at you I'll jerk off to you
I mean I know that came out okay I was
just trying to make a point
but he essentially said the same thing
about
tell me what's what to jerk off to and
what not you know
is this weird thing instead of just
having some self-control do you want to
like limit women of what they can do and
so right like for example can you not go
to the beach women wear like
um bathing clothes
I mean they're still revealing and like
it just yeah that it feeds into the big
problem we have today slippery slope
dude slippery adult film stars on his
stream he said people had only fans on
his stream you think he'd be more
understanding of oh his the industry his
sister as only fans by the way that too
I well there's he used to do hot tub
streams that's how he got big what the
[__] spending time at home in early 2021
he moved to Los Angeles from Florida and
hosted a stream in a hot tub with fellow
YouTuber and twitch Karina Koff who is
the only fans girl right and streamer
and from the blog Squad right right
another viable moment that attracted new
followers since then things have been
escalating quickly bro why are you
becoming Taliban
these men all want to be Taliban
yeah it's crazy like they they the the
right has done a really good job at sort
of like repackaging
what is really just [__] ancient
puritanical you know controlling of
people's bodies
repackage it as as uh being anti-woke or
or you know their version of Woke
whatever you wanted to find that as red
pills do not come
don't have sex don't drink you know uh
woman should be dressed conservatively
and belong to you I mean this is these
are not novel Concepts this is this is
going backwards in time
regression perhaps you've heard of it so
here's Ada Ross uh yeah
I mean technically porn addiction and
[__] like that is real but instead of
like no I think women you should go to
like a therapist instead instead of like
yeah fixing the world or instead of
fixing yourself that's a you problem
yeah it's like so [__] dumb he's so
of course there's porn addiction you
know what I mean like and that is a
problem right
he's not first of all he's not I'm I
have to
take him at what he's saying I know he's
not that articulate and that's putting
it mildly
he's not very he's barely literate
but he's not talking about he's just
said people are jerking off and that's
the issue
by the way here's his sister who has the
only fans no that's nice sister that's
uh she's a streamer uh she's a fan of
the show actually Liliana oh shout out
little Leona yeah she does hot tub
streams and uh she responded with this
on Twitter Aiden having people DM
to be on stream while saying [__] like
this is hysterical dude you made so much
money funneling people to gamble just
shut the [__] up
dude
but people really watch Aiden for this
[__] this is boring as [__]
[__] you know
but here he is apologizing because he
was he
jerked off it's awesome
but I've got watch this this is a
serious
um confessional uh I'm so sorry guys I
gotta be real I bust I did jerk off you
loser
you have no self-control
yeah yeah
he just finished
in the bathroom
yay
yeah he's so guilty instant post not
Clarity instant like now I gotta get on
YouTube
he went from making that video the first
one right into the bathroom to jerk off
and then this one
um by the television I'm just gonna get
straight into it I let everyone down bro
um I'm honestly
I'm gonna take a full accountability for
it and I'm not gonna lie and cover stuff
up and I'm gonna let y'all know when I
slip and I fail and I and I and I
basically
um let Temptation take over
um why are you talking like a [__]
priest do you hear yourself bro
um
what what are you talking about it's
crazy last night guys I went out and I
drank
um you know I've been on this this
journey where I haven't been having
anything poisoned and toxic and you know
I've been in the gym and filled my mind
and my everything around my life I mean
like accordingly and um you know I just
feel horrible because I know this angle
is [__] awesome it's like his dick
talking yes
dick confessional it's the jizz on the
countertop wait he's looking back at him
he's talking about poison yeah you gotta
get the poison out dude no he doesn't
understand the equation he's got it all
backwards
he's trying to sound the semen back into
it oh God you got it backwards Aiden my
dear sweet Aiden
I just feel horrible because I know what
I was doing was strictly Temptation bro
you know alcohol is literally straight
from the devil bro yo follow me at
aidenross.com
jerking off the habits and uh
the little birdie
maybe Tate put out a message like boys
nobody jerk off until I'm out in
solidarity wow don't bust it out until
I'm free no nut for Tate
Temptation bro you know alcohol is
literally straight from the devil bro we
are not why he's like he's like he's
Taliban he became Taliban out balls
straight from the Devil
I mean yeah you don't even have to go
far in his Taliban I mean this is
standard [__] like born again [__]
you know what I mean like they drink
born against drink don't they not um
blood of Christ bro
well that that's that's Catholics
generally what you're describing that
wouldn't be like born again
it really just there's so many [__]
Christians it just depends I just don't
know what happened to my good bar
mitzvah boy Aiden Ross here you know the
Jews are down with drinking I'll tell
you that that's that's straight in the
Torah manischevitz yeah unfortunately
it's manischevitz so it's it's still
alcohol you know Aiden yeah dude Jews
are crazy there's this holiday pouring
it's like Halloween but what the goal is
to get so shit-faced that you can't tell
good from Evil anymore
[Laughter]
so and you're Jewish man
who are you yeah he he you know he's not
being a good Jew right now conscious
space you're not supposed to you you
can't even drive normally when you have
alcohol that's deep
that's good that's actually [__] deep
huh
that's actually a good point it's evil
because you can't drive I never like
thought about it like that yeah here's a
good point
[Music]
I hope he's not speaking from experience
though yeah I was gonna say maybe he
grew up home drunk I kind of got that
feeling is NyQuil evil or is that okay
if you can drive on it it makes you
drive differently no it says available
don't operate heavy machine straight
from the devil yeah okay okay I'm drunk
I'm just trying to parse out we got this
new wisdom from Prophet Aiden here new
rules we said cavcv disagrees that's
true he's not down with what he is
saying right now what else makes it hard
to drive
angry
that [__] cracks me up every time
uh this is super interesting you know
you're not supposed to be drinking
alcohols human beings we're not supposed
to be taking an alcohol
did drug use is like one of the most
ancient forms of human like experienced
literally people even uh there's
actually real scientists that
hypothesize that human consciousness was
born from our early use of mush magic
mushrooms yeah it's it's it's a fringe
it's a little Hocus Pocus but I'm just
saying
like alcohol consumption is like as old
as civilization that is the fact they've
found they've found they were fermenting
that [__] when we were still bro what
are you saying you're so dumb stop
talking you see you don't know what
you're saying stop it
some
some work lady [__] he's on his wart
lady era
hopping into work or lady
summer it's got warts on his brain
summer
we are not in a conscious space you're
not supposed to you you can't even drive
normally when you have alcohol you know
you're not supposed to be drinking
alcohols human beings we're not supposed
to be taking an alcohol can you look up
what's the earliest known
um
alcohol evidence it's got to be like
tens of thousands of years yeah yeah I
know all the way back man too much wine
even monkeys drink alcohol they found
some monkeys that drink fermented like
grapes and [__]
um
even Elks 7000 BC
7000 BC so that's like ten thousand too
much wine it's literally older than
civilization yeah yeah
I'm surprising go back further thank you
so I don't know what you mean supposed
to but I'd love to ask you questions
about all this and honestly bro I'm not
I'm not the type to like I told you guys
covered up and basically like something
driving isn't natural either Aiden
that's a great point it's like
it's interfering with my natural right
to drive an automobile driving is yeah
that ain't natural drinking alcohol is a
lot more natural than alcohol first
driving second in terms of Nature and
also uh jerking off that's pretty
natural too oh man true bro trust me
we're natural in any of those cavemen be
jerking off sure thing bro
do you think chimps and bonobos that's
like all they do all day all day every
day
true yeah I've been into the zoo I see
them jerk off into their own mouth
that's natural
it's called autofellatio
[Laughter]
to get into it Aiden that's just natural
yo somebody tell Aiden that eating your
own semen gives you like super
can you believe that testosterone powers
or something he totally believed that
jacket off
oh [__]
this this man is dumb yeah I didn't do
that like no where I really messed up
last night I did it so I'm letting y'all
know right now
um I'm sorry for everyone that I let
down and um now I can really really
understand how you know how serious
um bad that is you guys know I've been
sobriety of everything you know as of 20
20 23 I've been no set did he add
another 20. 2020 2023 how many that's
like you've always been doing that
it's funny but
this is so unfunny dude stop goddamn x
no masturbation you know just clean raw
diets working out every day I'm still
going to the gym today I I haven't I
haven't missed anything at the gym my
body's been looking like I said I had a
nice little transformation I'm really
happy I saw some results you guys
actually showed it to me I'll pop a
little picture here you guys can see
well oh
nice
[Music]
[__] joked all that semen retention's
been we're paying off
he's got all that extra
with a raging headache and just horrible
thoughts and literally just gloominess
and sadness bro I was just so sad and I
was texting people that I wouldn't have
texted when I would you know I was
basically texting girls no and I
shouldn't be texting girls no because I
was texting him because I was horny
Aiden do you think that this is like a
confessional at church or something like
why are you telling us this
do 20 Hail Mary's
do 20 Nancy Reagans and 22 flip ditty
flops
what's Hail Mary even mean does that
just mean hey it's a pleasure to marry
it's like a prayer that you memorize and
say a bunch for magic words Hail Mary to
a spin say Beetlejuice three times
that's exactly it yeah
because I'm so celibate I'm over 20 days
celibate now so I'm ultra horny you know
this is like where like it's getting
super duper hard
um that's ironic right
awesome dude okay the jokes are back
foreign
ly curious like if anybody's enjoying
this content of his old fans but but no
for real though like I you know thank
God I didn't I didn't you know nut but
you know it's just it's just crazy the
Temptation is really trying to take over
but wait I promise you guys
he just said thank God I did not
whoa it doesn't count
yeah that counts right
so what he just touched it a little he
just touched it a little so bombing and
he feels bad about that oh my God don't
feel bad about that yeah you're good
you're still accomplishing your goals
yeah I don't think it counts yeah I
thought he was going to hell for a
second yeah you're good brother
I just hope he wasn't driving when he
was doing it good point definitely not
safe to drive and jerk off at the same
time
no it'll affect the way you drive
super yeah
be better and uh I'm gonna make sure I
get myself a full cleanse I'm gonna go
to the gym sit in that sauna for at
least 20 minutes today and just sweat
everything out and just you know
someone's gonna walk into that sun and
see him beating off
you know
maybe that's why he invited you over
you want you think he wants me to milk
his brush I mean his you know Tate's not
around maybe he's lonely wants someone
to come for him yeah you know what I'm
gonna sit in my dress right now we'll
see what happens
look Ethan
I invited you out here today
because you're the oldest person I know
and I need someone to cosplay is my dad
he was edging himself true
[Music]
anywhere I go from here is going to be
inappropriate so I'm not even gonna do
it I'm gonna stop myself now 20 20 23.
[__] you [__] you
[__] you still be on my cries they'll be
on my [__] now and I hope you guys can
forgive me and uh I forgive you see that
uh this will happen again I love you
guys I'm gonna stay true to myself I'm
always gonna stay true to you guys and
uh yeah yeah bro we don't need an update
that you touched your dick a little bit
you know
not that important of an update you
didn't even not
as long as the semen stays in the ball
sack you're good yeah
that's what I think too and if there's a
little pre-cum you can just sound it
back in
Ross gin Ross
oh bro you have gone so awry
this is your brain on Andrew Tate ah
yeah so here's the video of him reacting
to us my video that I obviously made was
a total goof
um about Urgent Message for Aiden Ross
and I said I'm Morpheus and he is Neo
and he needs to wake up
so here it is
wait it's 13 minutes [__]
that's probably good
it's probably good let's give it a shot
I've got this oh he says I should be in
jail for what because I have Tourette's
was that it uh he says your your pupils
are big and you're on something oh yeah
here he he he I would say he's a coward
I mean he's kind of going against the
entire world
but oh so he shows that I'm hair
oh dude
I wouldn't say he's a coward I mean he's
kind of going let me just watch the
whole thing this is going to be [__]
he's gonna be good
so yeah
Ross he was banned on Twitch okay six
minutes Somebody went into his live
stream and sabotaged him what happened
was he was doing some GTA 5 role playing
and somebody I do love that he watched
my videos I knew he's gonna watch that
it's awesome dressed up like Adolf
Hitler yo I love Ethan Klein bro I don't
care anyone oh he's the best
he's not he's he can be saved he can be
saved
that's the most painful thing says like
dog I love this guy I love I love him it
doesn't matter I I love him he says
things that I don't agree with sometimes
maybe we share some beliefs with we
share different beliefs but I still love
him and I respect his beliefs yo um
but guys I didn't get banned because
of Hitler I got banned because I grabbed
Bilu I picked him up and I [__] them
on the on the car so that's why oh [__]
I'm gonna erase my video into his game
to try to get him banned and he did get
banned and do you know why that happened
most people are missing the true story
here do you understand
what the Matrix oh my God they actually
are probably you know they they they
they they probably are to be honest uh
if we're you know I don't know
to be fair
I've been doing like sex RP for [__]
years on Twitch
as soon as I tell kids to stop watching
porn
and do push-ups
I get banned for a week
that's the Matrix bro that you've been
doing it and now all this all of a
sudden they're turning on you that's
where you need to listen to me I'm
Morpheus kids loved Hitler
maybe the Matrix is after me then you
might be right Ross and this is why I'm
making this urgent urgent message to you
what you thought that Andrew Tate is
gonna be your Neo but I have a bad news
for you oh Andrew Tate what is actually
going to be your agent Smith I don't
understand that stop what do you need
I get the reference I I just can
somebody break down that reference Aiden
alive
he doesn't understand
a joke
if he's never seen The Matrix before I
guess you know he doesn't know who
Adrian Smith is yeah if you guys hang
out you should definitely watch it
together
Matrix reaction and you can explain
stuff as you go along that could be
transformative yeah you could be his
Morpheus am I just showing him
that's meta I like it
I don't understand the reference I don't
get it
oh my God what does it mean I try to put
this in terms that I thought you would
understand I was like maybe if I put
this in a matrix analogy
he'll get it no
I know who Neo is from Matrix but I
don't know who agent Smith is
this bro you went to the Matrix yes but
oh the villain the villain okay yeah do
you know what I'm saying
I'll I'm Morpheus bro I feel like he
could have inferred that without having
to stop the video and ask
this is the matrix it's real in the
words of Logan Paul he says
The Matrix is real and pray that it
never comes for you well I've got a bad
message for you Aiden The Matrix is
coming all right buddy what kind of
drugs are you on look at his [__]
pupils the size of like the [__]
equator bro like dog this dude
size of the Equator brown eyes
because Ethan's in the dark your pupils
enlarged in the darks like more like a
lot more light in right then camera lens
that is accurate yeah I mean your iris
opens it wasn't that bright it was just
a weird angle you couldn't really make
out my pupil for my Iris wait but the
equator reference am I am I missing
something no that was a bat because they
quit the size of the Equator the equator
is just the circumference of Earth right
so that's right
yeah no like here's the equator you turn
it on your side and then that's the size
of your size
the size of the Prime Meridian all right
like high off like a [__] like Acid
Trip [__] on Molly ass like
meth what the [__] is he doing bro Ethan
listen my brother this is it is
definitely meant to be like kind of like
an acid trip with the Matrix [__] so
there you go I feel like you have met
your match on flip-flopping of like I
love you I hate you I love you I hate
you I know you guys are very simple I
can't decide Aiden can we let's hang out
tomorrow so funny
I'll be like this I can show you the
world
he can be Jasmine
shining shimmering splendid we can do a
duet
when I got banned so I'm not I'm not
brother he's like what's Aladdin Aladdin
can you someone explain that he's gonna
watch this and be like chat can someone
explain that who's Jasmine
oh my God he's gonna pause it ask and
then he's gonna play it and then see
this I'll do a highlight then I'll put
like explanations for everything you say
yeah and that's important that's
important highlights yeah and we'll put
a glossary
um a little mini thesaurus for you in
description
defining any word over four letters
you already shaved your red ball this is
great I'm waiting for you and I to meet
up in person no cameras on I want to
give you a hug and I want to take you
out to a nice cup of coffee I don't
drink coffee anymore maybe I'll have a
cup of black coffee okay but uh or maybe
I'll bring my my protein shakers let's
just talk that's that's a drug too yeah
I'm just saying yeah you just no cameras
just you know get some coffee get to
know each other I'm telling you Mormons
don't drink coffee too you're right bro
if I did that he would be he would fall
in love with me like like in a dad way
he'd be like bro I need to I need you
know what I mean yeah I could easily if
I was a high functioning psychopath like
Andrew Tate I would go and he would be
mine
take a baseball with you play some catch
or something actually I'll sign it for
him
I can chat bro
there's a reason you got banned on
Twitch I love you bro but hey you're on
something brother
looks scary right now bro I do look kind
of tripped out there I'm not even gonna
have to pull that again pupils I think
he
it's just dark your pupils look normal
size listen I'm in a hotel room with my
two sleeping children wife and
mother-in-law trust me I was not turning
up
that day yo I'm not gonna lie this is
the devil this is Satan bro I'm not bro
I did look at that
this is Satan
you're gonna Splash holy water oh good
holy hell
[Applause]
you're on his computer it's not a coin
that's really smart yeah he is he's
gonna be like The Matrix
three yes it's a year then come with me
you want the red pill or you want the
blue pill which pill we take in chat red
or blue I'm just saying dude what are we
gonna do I'm just saying I'm be near
okay I'm gonna wake up with you I will
show you for the first time ever and it
might not be pretty much like when Neo
woke up it was not pretty
uh-huh but it's real and that's what's
important do you want to sleep or do you
want to wake up
Aiden Ross wake up you want to keep
getting banned and sabotaged no like
provocateurs and agent Smith's or do you
want to take my hand
uh Morpheus and go and become the one yo
yo he's literally on something bro I
don't care I I love you Ethan I love you
it doesn't matter
you are the one Aiden Ross you are going
to save us all
right what's the name of their uh yeah
yeah
it's fine I know that people don't
understand I was ticking really bad
I was stressed out about like Shredder I
was finding out about all that kind of
stuff and or I was my mom took him to
the vet I didn't know he was but yeah I
was stressed out I kept doing this weird
tick where I was lifting my head up but
I I don't I'm not mad at him or anything
it's totally fine
I understand it's weird if you don't
know what's happening yeah
like balls like yeah I
I bro
wait Chad why is he almost like an acid
trip and the first thing he thinks about
is me
because because I always think about you
Aiden
it's all about you you're Neo bro
you know the city under yeah I see I see
his chat saying you have Tourette's now
yeah and I don't ever get mad when
people do that it's totally fine like if
I saw someone and I didn't know what
Tourette's was it's easy to just think
like it's weird and that's fine
hmm
y'all shouldn't get mad at him for this
it's not a big deal and they're like
this is uh this is that's well you're
gonna be the king of that city thank you
yes yes even yes so the question is are
you gonna follow the cat the girl with
the cat tattoo are you gonna go watch
this rabbit that one Really Gonna Give
You yeah no no what yeah sleep all right
never happened Chad what Aiden Ross
Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate are in a
jail cell right now yes they are
okay yeah you know what that means you
remember the bad the guy from The Matrix
who he double crossed them and he killed
one of his own guys so that he could be
put back in the major yo I'm scared of
this guy and you remember how Neil met
him and he was eating yo this is
literally scary bro you should be
mistake and you go you never heard such
facts before
it was
he goes you know what I realized about
the Matrix this takes this steak tastes
good and I just don't care anymore
that's educate bro you want to be played
like one of those idiots or you want to
take my hand i'm Morpheus I know how am
I being played though by the advice he
gave me to basically make my life better
and I'm bro it's the steak
it's just the stake analogy work with me
already happy and I'm more consistent
I've ever been on streaming and better
my life than I've ever been
I don't understand why people really
like hate dog I'm happy I work out now I
go all walks now I do things for me like
I literally changed my entire like wait
those shirts are all great hold on hold
on there this comment here from
Danes is a similar tourettes it gets
harder and harder to excuse someone for
being ignorant on it it used to not
bother me but it's slowly starting to
you in my opinion we can't let it bother
us dude people don't know it's not a
really common thing and it's just going
to be hard if you're walking around
getting angry because everyone doesn't
know about your it's a somewhat obscure
condition let's be real
um and and I know it just doesn't bother
me and I don't think anyone should be
mad at Aiden I really want to say that
to the extent that people know what
Tourette's even is they only know about
like the verb yeah exactly people don't
even understand other stuff right right
totally
so don't be mad at Aiden he I don't he
doesn't he's not trying to be like
ableist I love that I'm I'm part of the
ableist though that I'm right like you
can abilize me
sure right sick I don't know if that's
phrased can I get a handicap uh placard
Lena can you look into that
chair
I need some privilege for my able being
disabled oh is that what it was from
Able disabled I'm disabled yeah it's
awesome
don't you get discounts and [__] for
that
Chad is Right Chad is right I'm disabled
me and Keem are gonna go get a discount
from like Cheesecake Factory together
we're both disabled
and I'm like [__] bumping
I don't get it like God I just don't
wanna know that's all I want to know I I
I I I want to know that
people say that's a bad role model
eating [__] okay that's your belief
that's your opinion you know but if if I
look up to somebody and they've made me
be motivated to be in the gym and eat
healthy and and and love people and
spread love what's the issue
oh what's going on
I mean it's fine it's good there's no
problem with any of that nope you're
good you're good it's good that you're
getting awesome bro
guys
Aiden Ross yo liko this is a serious and
Urgent Message for you what that's funny
actually that's pretty good I've never
seen that comparison I've thought I've
seen it all
pretty original yeah pretty original
the way I trim my beard doesn't help
my neck beard is pretty patchy so I
gotta cut it
it doesn't do me any favors
pretty funny that's funny is the uh
Bobby Hill from the other day but it's
pretty good
the Bobby Hill's the best I can't live
ever lived that one down it's an urgent
message for you what
there's a reason that your hairline
keeps receding do you see it do you see
that was a good one
mine looks like I'm like 65. it keeps
growing down
it's because I understand oh so what
you're saying is I have to cut Andrew
Tate off to get a better hair look yes
you understand now okay okay he's
starting to believe
okay okay and I promise you this Aiden
Ross tell me you take my ham yes is it
the red pill the good one or the bad one
the red pill is the good you're the
you're
chat is the red pill the bad one or or
which one's the best the good one
red is good that is the one that gets
you out of the Matrix I mean it depends
who you ask right blue is bad you're
definitely the blue pill Ethan if you
take the red pill
because uh never mind because I actually
he doesn't I don't believe in batter
dude no you're Ethan you're you're
somebody who needs Ethan is smart as
[__] and I like him a lot like I said I
I I love him it's just go on he went
ball chat let's give a chance yeah your
hairline when you wake up out of the
Matrix you guys have like three
different combos yeah with himself look
listen is it the red pill the good one
or what's the chat listen here's the
good one
if you take the red pill
your hairline when you wake up out of
the Matrix your hairline is perfect bro
because Andrew takes a jealous [__]
because he didn't even have any hair oh
has a hair transplant and it's just
really bad that's why he shaves it all
Aiden he's jealous because you have a
real hairline oh so he shows that I've
hair
dude
I wouldn't say he's a coward I mean he's
kind of going against the entire world
he's been like canceled like three times
and just like still was like the most
famous [__] like one of the most
famous people ever like on Earth he
loves him he's got so much respect for
it for Andrew that birth right now so I
don't know human trafficking coward with
no [__] hairline all right Ethan all
right let's let's sem it down a notch
huh Ethan you have to listen for a
second okay technically you know you
should be in jail right now too buddy
hey I'm not gonna snitch but you're on
[__] something that is obviously
illegal Hey listen again
I I'm pretty sure he's kidding but drug
use is
it is human trafficking y'all should be
in a Cell together
acid
and human trafficking
now
um we love you though Ethan we love you
you're so much better than that bro he's
I love Ethan right Ethan man bro come on
dude if you want me to show up at your
house yes of course bro you want my
address here
right now this is the moment yeah I've
been saying you could pull up bro you
know I uh
and I was like what do you want to do
with this bro
so I'm gonna come tomorrow Aiden
you invited me
like a vampire I couldn't come otherwise
[Music]
this is my thing it's like brother
you can you can pull up on me I would
love to talk to you
but any hate at all
any type of hate at all you're you're
you're you're you're going to be asked
respectfully nicely to leave because I'm
not here to talk about hate I'm not here
to talk about useless conversation I'm
here to gain some [__] and spread love
so I'm gonna send you my address
I won't show up uninvited he did
he did do it he did do it but I'll wear
full leather
um yeah trench coat glasses whatever you
want
dude
you want the don't ask for that to be
explained please bro that would be
awesome he was thinking about it if you
win the trench coat and glasses [__] but
he doesn't get that reference for sure
we gotta do that before I go yeah
definitely we gotta get the Morpheus we
got the glasses and I'll bring a bottle
of pit of red and blue pills
got the glasses right here but do we
have I need like a leather jumps or we
do not leather well let's order one on
Amazon
what's the whole Morpheus look same day
same purple purple dress shirt and then
the trench coat over it with the glasses
I can I can postpone it till the
outfit's ready oh this is important you
got to strike while the irons hot you
think so but I think it would be so
worth it to show up as Morpheus dude I I
literally will go you might uninvite you
every day I'm so excited about seeing
this I will go look for a trench coat
by tomorrow come on
yeah the whole outfit it's literally
just a trench coat and the glasses are
all that someone says drop acid you know
what they do have the morphe's glasses
they don't have the sides they just clip
onto your nose oh those are fire those
are legit oh true right he's too [__]
cool for arms on his glasses
[Music]
all right well let's see what we can do
red Advil you want the daytime Advil or
the night or you want the DayQuil or the
NyQuil all right buddy you want to sleep
you want to take this is the night
oh you want to wake the [__] up and take
that day quilt what the [__] are you
saying gets a little pep in your step
listen Kareem I don't care if he leaks
it bro I don't care
I don't care for these my address bro I
literally it's already leaked like
literally for one and for two like what
does he think I'm gonna I'm gonna post
your address on Twitter
come on
not you guys not you guys bro not you
guys you guys are not allowed no message
to Aiden Ross if you know him please
make sure he sees this
if you are tired of getting swatted if
you are tired of being raided getting
banned on Twitch
it's time to wake up brother The Matrix
is after you
Logan Paul called this okay
and I'm real I'm Morpheus bro chat stop
chat you know
I don't know who you got to have a love
interest I don't know you're single
right you're kind of lonely yeah you're
lonely and single actually can I tell
you something Ethan in chat bro I used
to think to myself like I'm never gonna
find a girl no I realistically I'm
probably never gonna find a girl you
have 22 dumb ass shut up oh yeah yeah
you're literally a child
he's being bullied into becoming an
insult like you have this like young man
who's like you know he's not like great
looking but he's not unattractive you
know what I mean and he's got a good
personality lots of Charisma he's famous
he's got money he's 21 22 years old and
he's literally being bullied into being
a [__] loser by Andrew Tate it's
insane I was bullied because I had red
hair
oh [__] that's true bro I gotta save you
from incel dumb man
he's got a nice Jewish punim
you know he's got a good bag he's a good
Jewish it's so true though you have it
all man you should be dating you should
be getting out there mixing it up go on
j-dayden Jay date all day we go crazy
find find that you know
find that Jewish girl for you mm-hmm or
use me for something in any way
I won't but I'm okay with that bro I'm
okay with that you know um you know I
genuinely feel like especially in L.A
maybe maybe if I move my
move so it might happen
I'm not I'm not looking a girl because a
girl will come when it's ready you know
I don't I don't I I I I I can't ever
date a la girl for one for two
um you know
there's a city of like what 10 million
in the LA County
I mean I get what he's saying because
I'm sure his circles there's probably a
lot of materialistic vapid people that
he's hooked up with over the years but
yeah there's
mm-hmm there's more than just that it's
a big it's a big town you know it's a
big town
there's nobody out there for me that it
makes sense you know
I'm so my standards are very high and it
has nothing to do with looks again a lot
of you guys think oh she doesn't have a
fat ass or fat tits oh my God she's mad
or ugly bro no
yeah okay I mean your homie did call my
wife ugly because apparently she doesn't
have both enough Botox but go on I mean
he defended her and in all fairness yeah
that was
[__] sometimes it doesn't matter about
how beautiful a girl is or how bad how
beautiful her body is because I already
told you guys this in six months when
you guys start fighting about stupid
pointless [__] it doesn't matter it
doesn't [__] matter you want a girl
who's cool as [__] who who thinks who
thinks like a boss who acts like a boss
I have a very particular taste I'm
trying to find a girl as dumb as I am
and those are not easy to come by puff
it is tough out there people
dude if me and Hayden had a podcast to
be so fire though
don't you think so yeah I don't know
about that it would be so good it would
be very good because he has he matches
the
she who will not be named uh
Andy matches you right I feel like the
way that you guys yeah like let me let
me put in a way that maybe I can get
away with I also think there's a chance
Aidan Ross doesn't know what gravity is
yeah I got you yeah you know what I mean
I got you
it's [__] sexy that's what you want
you want to self-respect and
self-independent women
dude and you're friends with Andrew Tate
okay
woman and and that is what I want but
it's gonna come to me one day and I'm
not gonna look for it and that's facts
push-ups oh y'all 15 I know
also we need to find you a love interest
that you could be Trinity for you
because that's
that's the what motivated Neo right
because like
you know what I mean he's got a he's
gotta have a little something to fight
for some some hot mama Trinity you know
Neo was about to like let it all go to
hell because except he just wanted to
[__] Trinity again
he was he was like [__] this [__]
and he's like wait
at the end of the second one I need that
Trinity so we need that
City you got a trinity we gotta find you
a trinity bro all right bro what is this
guy saying though
all right you see
I'm surprised you lasted it this long in
the video frankly pretty incredible of
course that
respectful
[__] little mini speech and then
somebody just has to say that bro
you should reply to this video with only
quotes from The Matrix likes only quotes
from The Matrix and nothing else I would
take a lot of effort
I just look it up look
I think it'd be that hard and then his
reaction would be great
be so confused
Chad explain this I'm in traffic though
we're going to treat her with respect
and dignity right Aiden because I know
no I would not get a Fable I would not
no no I would not wait did I say
something about fat girl I don't know I
don't know yo oh my God that's all fat
shaming I'm gonna tell you why I'm about
the gym now I'm all
[__] goes to the gym twice and
let's cut him off there okay that's a
good place to stop
so um
I'm all about the gym now I will say
props to Aiden for sitting through that
whole video that was obviously a
manic ravings which is what it was you
know meant to be
of a literal method or or not manic but
maybe like psycho
like uh meth fueled meth field maybe um
by the way thank you too
lowick loic l-o-i-c
like
um
for defy gifted also I don't know what
these are but there's like stickers now
far CC did a
stickers yeah there's like a yeah you
can just do like gifs stuff you can do
that when you don't write a text oh and
Farsi also gave uh cool video game one
it's cool dude thank you bro
Epic
there it is we did learn one thing Aiden
Ross is not dating fat chick no way dude
he's been in the gym three times since
the new year and he is not dating fat
chicks
foreign
kind of a gym rat now so I don't know so
he has the pass yeah
how long we've been going I'm trying to
get home at like a reasonable time oh
well then we should probably wrap it up
because we've been going for almost
three hours okay good yeah I'm trying
we've been what up what was that I'm 40.
I'm tired I'm sweating I'm overweight
dude that was insane how you start it's
how you stopped it it sounded like he
was here
oh yeah we didn't uh actually talk about
we didn't talk about MILF Manor after
all that wait we have to talk about MILF
Manor you know what else we have to talk
about what
Cam went and saw Avatar 2 this weekend
and he said okay
go ahead cam it was [__] awesome dude
we got another convert tell me what tell
me why you liked it uh it was exactly
the same as Avatar one but it was
re-skinned in the water so there was
fishes and whales and [__] coral
reefs and it was pure uh very pretty and
that's why I liked it because it was
pretty
and it was a fun action and it was good
and James Cameron Fox
all right I want to change my name to
James Cameron Grant did you like the
story it was fine you know so the story
was lackluster
yeah it's got a you know a fast and
furious thing going on it's surrounded
around family serious yeah it's very uh
family oriented so it's about the family
dude
that was yeah because it like he said
it's a reskin of the first movie you
could even call it a soft reboot except
there's a bunch of like kid blue people
now as part of the dynamic instead of
just the The Love Story between the two
of them and that's a better it's a
better angle because the main dude is
not that interesting but he hits the
kids are the kids are the kids are fun
characters so wait they had kids yeah
what happened to him he he at the end of
the first one he got to be turned into
one of them yeah he's just a blue guy
now yeah and this is like permanently
with four or what is it four fingers or
whatever that's the big oh he has
different amount of fingers yes and
people think he's freak so what happens
the humans came back for more or
something they came back for something
else oh they found another valuable they
found another one of a kind valuable
mineral that is actually a lot
uh more interesting than just generic
mineral that's buried neum I remember
for yeah no no more on obtainium I think
they realized that was kind of that was
kind of dumb so what they gotta see it
Ethan you're going you got to see it I
don't want to give it away it's a it's a
plot point I'm gonna watch it on my TV
no active Rebellion
how much I like it
good story is overrated dude I just want
something flashing in front of my eyes
dude that's this and this is the movie
for you bro I'm fully doubted why is
this right now do they have a a version
with Subway Surfer in the top right and
the frame rate's changing constantly
it's e it's in IMAX it's got Subway
Surfer footage playing on top of it
overlay all right all right maybe I'll
see it maybe I'll see it
all right let's talk about MILF Manor so
MILF manners on TLC I'm finally learning
a deal finally the learning channels put
out something educational
MILF Manor puts eight older women in a
house with their young Sons
they're in Mexico because the incest
laws are more relaxed there adult
incestors actually that's a joke but
what is it Mexican I got into this
I got into this um
hole with my brother he we were talking
about milk you got into a hole with your
brother and you talk about incest yeah
and then holy my brother trying to find
out what the incest laws were apparently
incest is legal or federally but it's a
states that ban the incest the incest
okay which kind of surprised me but I do
Wonder are there any states where it's
not illegal I think all 50 states say no
incest but then we got what where does
incest when does it become incest third
cousin is that incest
third cousin I don't think so isn't it
just first cousin first cousin cousin
second cousin you're good legal yeah
so basically anyone outside of your
immediate family wait wait no I think
you can't I think you can marry your
first cousin it just if you guys have
different last names wait wait
you can you can so it's not because
they're insists to be with your cousin
your first cousin because that's pretty
close oh I just looked it up bro
okay according to this website there are
two states in the United States where
incest is legal California has to be one
of them
hell no California no they're not the
ones you would expect though is it New
York is one of them
no New York but you're close tell me
tell me tell me it's New Jersey I knew
it everybody and Rhode Island makes
sense according to this website all
different things in New Jersey
incest legality New Jersey so you can
[__] your mom in in New Jersey and it's
not illegal well let me drill down and
see if it's if it's specifically like
talk about first cousin or something
okay so 24 States prohibit marriage
between first cousins California allows
it with first cousins
okay oh it's the first cousin is legal
in California no I'm sorry cousin
marriage is is legal first cousin is not
that isn't first cousin cousin first
question right that's what confused me I
think it's saying like anything beyond
first cousin is okay so half States you
can you can marry your cousin
uh according to what that's called
cousin is very close it's pretty close I
know I I don't want to say too much but
I know cousins that are married
I actually
wait I want to know everything I've
dated a girl dude this is kind of not a
girl I dated in college she was Farsi
and her parents were first cousins
pretty gnarly wow my grandparents she
was she was very mentally ill too by the
way I don't know if that's related yeah
it could be you know yeah my uh my
grandparents were second cousins so I'm
second is a lot further than first right
I agree it's not too bad and it's
interesting I think well you know this
is the this is the Jewish side of the
family and you know it's a little
those ashkenazis they like to keep it in
the family you know what I'm saying dude
I'm so glad that I got to have kids with
Ela because I know because my genetics
are [__] nuts
far away so I'm glad I got to get some
news
it's so much better for the kids trust
me of course yeah
it's actually super
like my mom has five nieces or nephews
that are married to her other nieces and
nephews first cousins
five yeah at least whoa yeah I hate to
say it but at least my the way that my
ex explained it is that it's pretty
normal in her culture yeah for cousins
to get married yeah it's some Game of
Thrones [__] and in terms of the kids
though in the gym like they're all fine
right
there it is but they ended up divorced
some of them my uh cousins out there
don't be afraid to uh Love Is Love wait
when they end up divorced do they still
have to like go to holidays and stuff
together
but they were already family to begin
with right well I'll answer that for you
my cousin Tim's parents were cousins oh
no wonder he's so [__] up yeah and
they do not go to the same get-togethers
anymore their parents that's a shame you
lose your significant other and a cousin
I I'm surprised I'm surprised the cousin
marrying is like cool because again
that's your sick your siblings
or your aunt's child I mean that's
really close yeah it's really gross it's
really gross I agree but uh
I don't know if I'm supposed to respect
people's cultures on that one or I mean
if you're not did they grow up together
yes come on uh yeah well not I mean you
say come on but yes they did I mean in
most these cases it probably did so we
grew up together they like were like
then that's definitely well what does it
mean situation was born when his dad was
42.
what's your argument bro against incest
come on here take a look uh Feast your
eyes
cousin [__]
cousin marriage is legal and the great
state of California brother and sister
want to make love
first cousin marriage is prohibited
I mean
first cousin married
look at the states we got California
Texas Florida and New York I mean all
the most populous states I gotta say the
United States seems pretty [__] cool
cousin yeah I'd say so and then even you
have like some Nuance first cousin
marriage is legal under
circumcircumstances so we gotta analyze
God's relationship and that includes
Illinois one of the other most popular
states I mean it seems like the vast
majority let's get out there and start
[__] country is cool with it let's
get out there
like at least by population that's
that's most the country right there
North Carolina permits first cousin
marriage though it prohibits double
cousin marriage what does that mean
if two brothers from one family marry
two sisters from another and if each
couple has a child those children would
be double cousins okay that's pretty
easy
you can only break the rules once now
these people are in the incest Matrix
well you know I've been watching Sister
Wives and that sort of is a similar
situation where everyone is
like this guy has four wives and then
his second wife was married to his first
wife's brother sister and then his and
also his second wife's mother married
his father as the third wife so I could
see it happening in a situation like
that just genetically though it like you
don't want to have that you don't want
to do that in your own family like
social societally socially it's just a
it's just a really [__] horrible idea
well here's the thing like how for how
long have we like understood
the mechanics of that and why that's bad
like 100 years yeah a couple hundred
years maybe yeah 100 years versus like
thousands of years of like tradition or
whatever I'm not saying they should keep
doing it they shouldn't I mean listen
like you're in a [__] tribe and
there's not that many people then I get
it right
you know what I mean there's like five
families you don't have many options
okay
no I think we've known that for a while
because I think I read somewhere that
they kind of exchanged uh between tribes
back in the days and they kind of all
met so maybe they did know yeah I think
we've known for for a while yeah
because certainly like all of the
royalty in [__] Europe and [__] they
they did not care
at all about it biologically we're
geared not to want to have sex with our
immediate families and that's why I was
asking about the raising thing because
then at that point it's almost like it's
a sibling even if it's your cousin if
you like grew up with them then it's
definitely like weird but like if you
barely knew this cousin and they lived
in another town or whatever and then
you're like in an arranged marriage like
that seems different than like marrying
your sister
there's a couple actually who got
married and just found out after like 20
years of marriage that their siblings
they were oh God that's crazy yeah yeah
that's that honestly I've heard like
what do you do want to say you're in
love with this person you spent your
whole life with them and then you find
out like you gotta just stick with it
right you divorce I mean you've been
together for 20 years wow sister snapped
like genuinely that's so [__] crazy
somebody said his Dan's cousin hot or
something I'm not trying to defend it
here I'm trying to understand
why some cultures still practice this
kind of thing and I'm just I'm stating
like you have a hot cousin Dan I I don't
I don't have I don't have a hot cousin
no no disrespect to my cousins but
I heard your cousin thinks you're hot
well that's their problem
[Music]
yeah so uh where the [__] are you
talking about yeah MILF Manor oh so what
are the incest laws in Mexico that's
what started this whole thing my brother
legit thought that they moved it to
Mexico because incest laws are more
relaxed I was like you're like it's not
a problem in the United States
but they're not having sex with their
kids yeah no there's no incest going on
on this show yeah it's not actually like
quick search it's listed in a list of
countries
as legal in Mexico yo
um
Wikipedia
they're great legal
yeah they just have a well there's no
Nuance here it just says legal so
there's probably more to it than that
but so theoretically
in MILF Manor the mom couldn't have sex
with their own son that's a crazy
challenge you gotta ride the dick and
then decide which one's your son's Jesus
Christ
we could get him so sidetracked does
everybody did we even set up what the
show is properly for people yeah so MILF
Manor it's a show
where these cougars or MILFs or whatever
come who and they're all into younger
guys they like dating younger guys
deals it's a dating show and then they
bring out all these younger guys
and when they come out all the moms
realize it's all of their sons are there
to date
all the other MILFs now logistically
this must have been pretty crazy to set
up to find a sun mother combo who are
like decent enough looking to be on TV a
lot of them are kind of busted like the
dudes
I won't disrespect the moms like that
now the moms are actually pretty for the
most part but some of the dudes are just
like super weird and busted yeah it
seems like they all like like same one
or two dudes well yeah one of the kids
the son of that blonde crazy lady yeah
he looks like he's 16. yeah oh God I was
like gonna be a serial killer for sure
that's what I thought too
I've never seen someone in my life when
someone's keeping eye contact with you
and you move your head he moves his head
with you well he's talking it's so weird
also you know he's still damaged by
having hers oh yeah that's definitely
wait pull up a picture of her son you
gotta see how young this guy is
and these moms are supposed to try to be
like this I'm sorry but if one of them
sleeps with them that's a [__]
problem for me he's 20 years old
you gotta see this [__] picture dude
and so in the first episode
the moms play a game where they have to
feel up all the shirtless dudes to try
to pick which one is her son and if they
she picks her son they win the master
bedroom or some [__]
look at them look at this guy oh
you're asking 50 year old women to sleep
with this child
he's a [__] child the very first
night in the house his mom is trying to
hook up with another guy in the room
yeah and telling him to stop [__]
[__] so they they share a room
they're sharing a room the mothers and
the sons and she's already on night one
trying to [__] this dude and he's like
Mom no
oh another one they did a truth or dare
season two
and one of the moms admit that she slept
with his best friend and this guy's like
he's gutted he's like ready to end it
all bro this shows
you don't want to spoil it I don't think
so young she slept with uh his best
friend and she's crying I think she
thought it would just be like funny and
silly and cute he's devastated he's like
in the pool he won't get out of the pool
everyone's asleep he's naked he gets
naked he's drunk and gets naked and goes
in the pool and she's like trying to
talk to him and then she goes home in a
room and she's crying it's [__] crazy
so this rocks very excited for episode
to that is episode two right I still
have to watch oh yeah yeah
so
it's awesome dude and her name is so
young she's a MILF and her name is so
young too young oh yeah so young they
make so young jokes but it's too young
and I know that because of Rush Hour
they don't say Sue young she says so
young
okay it's I'm telling you bro
how old are the moms
they're like uh 50s to 50 plus yeah
isn't that
kind of gross and weird it's more like
Pete Rarity can you pull up a picture of
the cast yeah I have it in the dark if
yeah if you [__] this kid it is kind of
beautiful like look at him he's a child
it's very concerning that they made a
show about this I feel like well yeah
that's why we're watching I think all
the guys are above 20 right he's 20. and
I think he's the youngest
I mean that's still a crazy age Gap
they're all young 20s you know it's like
the Leo Leo Vibes where he just searches
out young girls
wait can you can you find a picture of
the cast yeah it was hard to find one of
all the guys that's right in this album
being Naruto
this one they actually they're like Mega
Photoshop so if you scroll down the guy
the guys are in that album though it's
kind of hard to tell this is so young
this is the lady who [__] the best
friend
they actually they look good because
they're like insanely Photoshop you can
tell
I mean not that they don't look good
they're just old
with peace and love of course
baby I need a I need a jewel pot listen
MILF is the most Apparently one of the
most popular search porn titles so
people love the MILFs oh here we go here
we go here we go
this is great so she's the craziest one
this is the woman who's trying to have
sex the first night and then the second
night she goes on this date this guy's
Mexican his him and his mom are Mexican
and they're speaking Spanish together
and she starts freaking out like no
nobody here speaks Spanish you bet guys
better speak English and she gets drunk
and starts getting crazy
awesome
and it's very uncomfortable when this
mom is in the sun because she just looks
like she has horrible sun damage and
that's all I can think about she looks
like the lady from Something About Mary
the old lady oh yeah I'm like please
just get this lady inside she's 51.
here is shannon51
what hold what am I waiting for oh they
didn't they couldn't see
I can see it now so yeah this is the
crazy lady
uh who's trying to have sex with
everybody
this is Shannon wait is this not working
again
[Music]
please hold oh yeah dude
one of the guys
in this Truth or Dare one this dude said
I've had a three I've had a orgy with
seven women I was like no you know yeah
you're such a [__] liar dude I'm like
he thinks he sounds cool he's just
describing a gangbang he got gang banged
if that's true like it goes he goes I
Did It For My Girlfriend this dude's
like 20 years old and he's telling me he
had a yeah
[__] liar
where's your daddy here's Shannon
Stephanie 47 she's the of course the
spring chicken of the group
at 47. so young bro just about your age
look at her name it says so young
literally
51.
she was a hair stylist now she's a
surgical nurse
there it is
so young
this lady is old as [__] Bro she's 60.
she's 60 years old and she looks like it
um in the show
she's a personal trainer okay
it's kind of crazy
she has not dated since her fiance died
last year
she kind of has a smoker's voice too
which adds another layer to it that's
amazing
she is like wow and then this was of
course Spring Chicken territory this is
the Mexican one 48.
and she hates her this is the woman
who's trying to get with her son and
they [__] hate each other dude MILF
Manor
mm-hmm
April 44 is barely a MILF
Charlene 46. so that's all of them huh
yep do we have the sons
uh it was in that album the original
album I sent it was hard to find a
picture of all them together I had a
screen nobody cares about the guys yeah
oh is it this imager album yeah
okay here we go
look at these dorks
literally children
who's going to want to have sex with
most of these guys like these women are
not going to have sex with these because
they had to set it up with the kids
and the moms
so their selection is not good like a
lot of these guys are just not [__]
at all
especially for an older lady
this guy can't even look up
yeah it's crazy because like you could
almost tell without knowing whose mom is
who like who they are based on how
messed up the kids seem like you can
tell who's you got to watch it to see
but the kids with the hornier moms are a
little bit more messed up it seems oh
yeah could be frank and um
this is one of these shows I just I'm
curious to see how bad it gets
and like is this going to be one of
these shows that just like people look
back and like I can't believe this
existed I think so or is it gonna get
season two because a lot of people are
watching it
you know
I'm watching the [__] out of it I'm on
IMDb looking at um
the executive producers uh previous
reality shows
and I mean a lot of these are pretty big
like iconic ones that people still talk
about years later so like what a track
record
uh Rock of Love with Brett hell yeah uh
traffic he worked on Big Brother for a
while okay uh let's see
uh
I mean I'm skipping over a lot there's a
ton on here but I'm oh New York charm
school with Ricky Lake and I'm vaguely I
remember that that was part of that
whole era it seems like all of those
like really trashy VH1 ones from back in
the day he had a hand in so I'm anyway
I'm super into
um
super into the show
it's [__] weird dude I have a screen
cap from the date on the episode I'm
trying to send right now yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes it won't let me screen
capture oh there's some fresh and fit
news actually I wanted to talk about
before we go
fresh and fit got walked out of Twitter
for being the biggest dumbasses ever oh
yeah this is this is this
this is the Mexican dude and this is
the girl that
they're dating I guess
I damn
I couldn't see her like sitting at the
end of a bar by herself spoke chain
smoking maybe a casino in Las Vegas
she's sitting at the slot machines with
the drink chain smoking
and then I just have one other screen
cap I want to share this is after the
one uh so young son found out that uh
found out about his mom hooking up with
one of his friends and he shot like this
Joker brain video oh this is a Travis
Scott vibes
yeah make it black and white and then
spot on
he's devastated man oh that's sad
yeah but it's funny for me
don't give a [__]
you think he's more mad at his friend or
his mom for that one
the world I don't know but she goes to
him she makes a good point she goes
listen I'm a woman too I have needs
you don't need to that is a crazy excuse
she goes listen I'm a woman too you know
what I mean you're not the only one
trying to get some I think it's kind of
sexist for him to be upset to be honest
um
we need the details okay
a punishment
a punishment for him should be that his
mom gives the whole play-by-play and
he'll still listen to it oh God
did they include him calling his friend
or no
no I wish no He did apparently he
doesn't know exactly who it was there
was like three
people there were three no he didn't
know of which ones exactly it was
because I don't think he wanted to know
it would eat me alive probably
imagine this is a dilf show with
daughters dads and daughters
that would be [__] crazy I mean yeah
that's
because it's all [__] when you flip the
genders it's suddenly like really hits
home just how [__] insane and [__]
I hate that but it's true well we know
what they should do they should need to
have like you know how bachelor and
bachelorette switch they need to have
the dilf and the MILF dilf what's rem's
with dilf
delft Dog House the Delph
dungeon
that's a very different show
then because dungeon's not gonna help is
it dwelling
the dilf dwelling
The delft Dugout
isn't it a little bit concerning to you
that the son of a older woman who likes
younger kids
likes oh yes that's what's so weird
crazy all of their sons who have this
hot mom all want to [__] older women
like it's super that makes me they
should have called this Oedipus I don't
like this show at all like I'm gonna say
it weird I'm gonna say it
you think it's fake I think some of it's
fake at least listen Okay no as soon as
you said that it just clicked that that
doesn't make any well that's why they're
also beat because they couldn't find
good people because it's like how do you
find two people in that relationship
they're all weird that exact same
dynamic
and you hide it from all of them because
none of them found out I'll say that
right I think they probably knew going
in otherwise I don't see any way they
could have coordinated it so they act
surprised in the first season but I
think they knew they'd have to yeah they
knew they knew what the show was
listen
we skipped over my Oedipus Island joke
Oedipus Island I think I mean that is a
good title for it well done thank you
well thank you thank you ancient Greek
can I explain that incest reference
there love that chat what is Oedipus can
you explain that I don't know what the
[__] this is talking about this dude is
talking about some [__] I don't know
what the [__] he's saying they go it's a
Dream It's a Greek uh
it's a Greek story what's Greek Greek
Greek I don't know what that is is that
a real place
is that a real precise high level humor
man
I thought that was like from God of War
OE dopas what's Oe dopis
I see people in the chat talking about
oh you dopists
so um
all right let me talk about
um
uh fresh and fit real fast dude these
guys
are insane picking coconuts in Barbados
they were dropping some crazy tweets
wait they're not banned
they're not band they were they were
locked out of their account
yeah just the lockout [__] Twitter's
[__] insane now
because these guys were just dropping at
like uh derogatory for gay people F
words like it was 1990. look at this
they said all these dudes are straight F
words the biggest critics are men you
don't want to be like see the
resemblance
and they only got locked out for that
that and several other uh
it said three tweets total I could only
find two of the ones that they got
popped for if you were just like the
look at these n words
yeah that would be bad would you get
would you get locked out just locked out
probably and and the new Twitter yeah
dude they're Pro hate that's awesome
yeah why Twitter is insane yeah so I was
like well that just tells you how like
severe it is that you that they managed
to get suspended even on this Twitter
like wait no I thought they just got
locked out well I'm using suspended in
the that's not they just have to erase
suspension they get back yeah
so um I had to yeah I had a record
scratch moment because I had to look at
the date I was like what year is it
I was like oh [__] that was like
yesterday yeah waiting out F words it
was so crazy to me here's some good
response I mean dude yeah my point about
this is like
he made a sneako I guess made a collage
of all the soy boys
who uh yeah criticized him
he responded my hair is coming back did
it trans flat nice try
I don't know man that's post-transplant
I'm growing my hair back people I also
if I could just shout out that dude on
the left up there he's a fan of the show
Jake Doolittle he took a pic he took
pictures of me at the crater class for
free great guy who dude with the glasses
oh this guy yeah lovely guy
you know what Jake do more
[Applause]
[Music]
here's Myron speedrunning uh Twitter TOs
hey guys if you're Hey guys you're gonna
start seeing more tweets from my room
fnf is going to take over this Twitter
space and talk all topics pepper by
Angus
that was on the 21st and then the next
day he got suspected he took over the
Twitter account and immediately just
started calling everybody F slurs and
then got suspended so
that really is a speed run
does he not know that you shouldn't say
that
he knows
you're so fragile bro Myron that's fit
right that is that dude is not coconuts
and Barbara yeah yeah I just remember
fresh coconuts that's how I remember
fresh coconuts right oh okay okay what's
his real name
[Music]
like isn't that the name of like the old
[__] Muppets on The Muppet Show that
are like screaming all the time old man
Walter and something right
um Myron design his real name either he
like changed it because he's like a fed
or something his name's like I'm real I
came from pronounce he chose the name
Myron he chose yeah incredible
thank you emo jalapeno for 10 gifted
love that love that love God
yeah but they should uh
yeah um Myron is probably the most
insecure person alive it's up there I
mean he is oozing with this fragile
masculinity this guy is so [__]
insecure
oh my God I know you guys okay I'm not
even gonna say it you guys get mad when
I say this
but here I want to look at sneako's
original tweet which is the one that he
retweeted
it includes me in it of course
as the original soy boy he says snico
whose band off of YouTube for
basically mock uh assaulting essaying a
girl
uh he says I forgive and love all the
soy boys that tried to cancel me what do
you mean tried
if any you could say try but your ass is
definitely gone
where are you streaming again Rumble
one of those
if even that
so here's all the soy boys here we are
okay Hassan he really okay he tried
I mean we all know song is like uh
a beast but okay whatever
he's really trying to say do you see the
resemblance because none of these people
look he's oh it was my room look at the
resemblance yeah
yeah we're all sorry
actually I don't know who a lot of these
folks are but here I am I look fat as
[__] I don't know if that makes me sore
but apparently it does in their world
but you know you can just grab a photo
of anyone and do like a thing like here
we made one with all the manosphere guys
let's see is this this is uh yeah here
let's take a look
I mean Andrew Tate
Tristan is literally American Psycho
looks like uh Frankenstein with a
yesified filter on him
well that hairline's definitely
Frankenstein
[Music]
these are all men that will uh look at
sneako's soy face let me just say this
you can right there going on a date with
these men's your memory is going to be
hazy in the morning right
[Music]
so we have Turtle Man Andrew Tate
[__] now this he is so [__] up
something's so unsettling about him he's
on something right I mean he's botched
he's botched yeah he looks botched
here is a uh what stymie
whoa what is soy face bro you want to
call anyone soy sneako look at this snow
this is the most soy-faced Ashton I've
ever seen bro you seriously want to call
anyone soy look at this beta [__] dude
when you become one of Tates goons does
he slit your eyebrow because Aiden has
the same is that a yeah I was wondering
if that's like a fashion thing or he has
a scarf it's usually a fashion thing uh
it is weird that they have in the same
place oh he looks like a wojack dude
I just sneak up really come on dude
explain this
yeah going down we have Myron who is
very soy-faced
ah and if I could see only see the back
of his head here now here's a really
sensitive wonderful bark coconut
oh
Barbados yeah we love his soft side
super Alpha
Jordan Peterson
who cries at the mention of Pinocchio
LOL and this of course is uh Rolo Tony
Brown town
who's like 60 years old and still
talking about red pill culture he's
blowing kisses to the haters man what
are you afraid of Ian so I can I can do
this to a guy
see the resemblance you see the
resemblance
oh man
yeah so anyway
yes we're all soy God got you
they're all wrong because they look gay
everything they said about me is wrong
because look how soy they look we're
high value soy boys dude they ate so
much soy that they're gay now dude they
talk about what it does to you
that's a big game man
oh sneako is so he's on a weird thing
he's talking about how like Doja cat is
a doing Satanism like what where where
are you
this is what I'm saying all like this
whole manosphere thing very predictably
is quickly just sliding into just dog
standard
religious conservatism well I I like
that don't masturbate don't drink you
know women women are subservient like
this is just
there's no
there's no breaking out of the Matrix
going on here like this you're just
becoming an annoying Church guy and they
believe in magic I saw a conversation
with some of these manosphere guys on
Tick Tock and they were legit debating
if women should be able to vote
but here's well there's I mean there's
two sides of every argument right
right we're just having an open
conversation you've got to look at both
sides that's what they always those are
cats wearing red and they're like oh
yeah she supports Satan uh but Tate who
confessed to basically doing all the
[__] up [__] he's done they're like oh
I don't know man don't believe
everything you hear even if the dude
himself says it don't believe everything
you hear everything else is a conspiracy
though
I'm not talking about him though this
what this look is [__] crazy
it's awesome looks like some Fifth
Element chip whoa what the [__] I know
it's nuts wait that's Dojo cut yeah yeah
um sneako well yeah there is a religious
element going on here says the prey day
keeps the woke away
yikes
but I like the Taliban analogy just
because these guys are probably
well I don't know because Andrew's like
converted now
and you you saw they were like openly
praising the Taliban when I say they it
was a specific set of people I just I
feel like these guys would straight up
be Islamic islamophobic as [__]
you know he doesn't know I mean like you
said Tate converted so I mean he clearly
wasn't but these guys have to be in
favor of like blowing up Iraqi Farms
I'm sure of it yeah maybe maybe
look at this one I've never seen a blue
haired they them non-barionary in the
gym
cool oh I got a great response to that
tweet it's still talking about
blue-haired people
got time to move on what do you got yeah
I'm sending it right now
right here
this isn't real
tell me this is real no shot what is it
oh my God no that's edited come on
people love editing Charlie Kirks you
have to tell me you have to find another
picture of him
he probably is a little gummy and then
they like stretched it to make it you
know what I'm saying because there's no
way
that's like the gayest generation in
American history looks like a president
that's such a meme to like Photoshop his
face that it it's it has to be fake do
some research maybe I mean this Twitter
person says it's unedited it's so funny
going under his tweets it's just all
photoshops of him in third place it's
relentless
yeah
this man is hideous
and I say that as someone who's like
ugly
and I think all people are beautiful too
yeah it takes one to know he's not
beautiful
he's a [__] not spiritual
he's foul man anyone find a gum received
some Charlie Kirk so you could just tell
like this story just look at it I didn't
I want to find the real one I found a
website that's called is Charlie Kurt's
face normal shrunken or enlarged and you
have to guess on each photo if it's
normal or edited okay I want to play
send me that he looks like a cenobite
wait you gotta try to find this picture
run it run it in like tiny eye or
whatever before a search engine
meanwhile take the Carly the Charlie
Kirk game oh no it's okay sorry it's not
an actual game but it was just it was a
tweet of what looked like a game got me
off yeah see here's another photo of him
where you can see he's got a very gummy
smile but it's not like that like that's
for sure like stretched yeah it's kind
of horrifying yeah it looks kind of like
uncanny
you can't find this photo I'm dying to
see the original well I'm seeing that
yeah
listen yeah oh Charlie Kirk's the one
that tweeted it
the woman who saved Western civil yo no
way
is so and I'm not even talking about the
gumminess
these literally become the Joker
literally I'm not gonna say anything did
we read the caption of the original post
of the Reddit post that said uh
right what is it of the
thanks AV the other tab
use your words
what was the title says makes fun of
liberals for looking weird and having
blue hair
that's good I like that that makes it a
little more Justified
if you go to any of his tweets go
carefully but it's just all edited
photos
if there's a photo of him oh underneath
go back to the yeah go back to the one I
see yeah any of his reply is just every
every single tweet I gotta get in on
this yeah you should yeah what the hell
I've been enjoying scrolling scrolling
that one's not Photoshop that one's real
yeah yeah I guess be careful it might be
yeah
oh [__] what is this
what the [__]
all right
this [__] is crazy dude all right that's
enough of that
and that's enough for me again we went
too [__] long as usual yep now what
we've done like four hours now or
something uh three and a half
all right guys what's today
today's Monday
it is Wednesday on Wednesday
thank you for the uh gifted to
my beautiful
my beautiful friends out there
Chef guy and you email jalapenos
whatever you think oh this is Joseph has
a great point with this donation that's
saying they've never seen a blue hair
they them in the gym is a Goku eraser
Goku racism
Goku Erasure
dude you never seen this dude in the gym
come on um yeah because he lifts the
whole gym
next
owned next so
tomorrow I'll be either showing up at
Aiden Ross's house or
doing a members only live stream I'll be
doing the member it's only live stream
for sure just depends on
what goes down with Aiden or not
you should live stream yourself going
there
that seems like a bad idea I just want
to show up
like you know like
like Jesus Christ this is who I am
here I am I'll show up in you know
naked or an underwear like with a trench
coat just here I am
I have no arms I have no camera I have
no bodyguard
you know
just like this
and I'll have one pill in each hand I
won't even say [__] he'll answer the
door
if he takes the red one I walk in if he
takes the blue one I leave
and that's it
all right guys
see you tomorrow members
love y'all see y'all on Wednesday God
bless God bless another great week of
shows
have a blessed week everybody
and we shall see you
next time
[Music]
foreign